it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was bryan when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
we got a very special fighter
and uh
jeff yeah yeah
last american bro yeah last american
no he's getting his lids done again and
he's getting a toupee so that's cool
it's funny because i love him so much
but it's really worked out for me yeah
it really has yeah that's how it goes
man the fighter on the bro somebody goes
we're like florida state somebody goes
down next guy's pretty good we want an
empty chair yeah
man
but we have to rally the troops because
our boy jelly roll is in la daddy yeah
baby bubba i never this first time i've
been in l.a in four years wow
well yeah you wouldn't want to be here
the past three it man
it's still about everything they it
wasn't as bad as far as like
you know like there was a lot man of
course i did the mass thing at kimmel
obviously but um funny oh that's disney
well that and i had to get i had to get
nose [ __ ] twice
i got nose [ __ ] twice
and it was crazy now you came to l.a
obviously to see me number one but
number two to do jimmy campbell yeah for
sure big deal believe it or not you were
you were the uh you and you hooked me up
with bird of course and that was like
the goal and i was like well yeah we'll
do camel while we're there yeah
third place third place i am like crazy
enough
on a podcast saying that your podcast
actually saying that i would rather
do
bert rogan your mom's house or anything
uh if i had to choose like if they were
like nine o'clock tonight you get to do
kimmel fallon or your mom's house i'm
like tom oh for sure right but also yeah
for sure and also tom's show is bigger
than that right yeah yeah you know
what's funny people don't watch tv
anymore yeah but as such a
like comedian fan it's just for me it's
like to go talk [ __ ] with the boys
yeah it's a fun hangout for sure and
then also i you know
you being on i think just like when you
told me on kim kim i was like oh that is
dope man because there's still that kind
of
you know that vibe be on kimmel you see
like it's just like you're blowing up
dude yeah
for me it was doing it because you're as
a kid like my mother's excited i'm doing
good yeah right you know what i mean
like she any late night tv she was like
dude like you know like her facebook has
been an omen to me playing tv for the
last week it's like just a homage so
this is a big deal and i like it because
i got to sing
like it's i get to come here and talk
[ __ ] there it was like it was a one
thing i sung see what i like what i said
today i said hopefully
jimmy kimmel like obviously
they're gonna let you perform i was like
if jimmy kimmel only knew how
entertaining jelly roll is they would
sit him down and give him a mic right i
know i campaigned for it when they sent
the email because uh chelsea handler's
filling in for him this week and i know
chelsea yeah i hit her i was like yo
[ __ ] like who's your guest that night
like punt one of them let me get on
there and talk to you guys
you know don't get me in trouble okay
you know what it doesn't matter i don't
know i can't pronounce either one of
their names well unless it was the rock
or kevin hart where they kicked him off
man i literally i felt so bad i looked
at the names and i'm like i butchered
them ain't that a [ __ ] i'm so glad i
didn't have to be like
but it's just a bummer because finally
you get on jimmy kimmel you're hoping
it's like i don't know oh he was like
shaq oh for sure i'm like give me pete
davidson give me give me pete you know
what i
was like just other comics that was the
worst yeah that was like a green room
hangout no way i mean i was like i was
like oh i wonder who this you hope for a
big celebrity because instead of not
only do you get to do the tonight show
but then you get to meet the celebrities
like you're saying and they're like oh
also on your show on your episode is
aziz and sorry you're like i saw him
last night at the cellar like that's not
i work with him man yeah
no no please book somebody else
and some of that girl i can flirt with
and yeah
yeah but i will say your camera with you
can put on your instagram yeah you'll
get the footage put that on your
instagram then a ton of people will see
it oh that makes sense nobody's gonna
see it on tv you'll get like 12 texts my
dad will see him you'll post on
instagram you'll get hundreds of texts
like congrats oh jimmy kimmel that was
awesome but you know that's how people
see stuff is on the internet what i hope
happens is is there's a small needle
that gets moved tonight
and it it helps me right not even from
like meaning like
jelly roll people tune in right now and
there's like a clear little thing that
happens where somebody from tv calls and
goes we don't know who the [ __ ] you are
but
more people tuned in for that seven
minutes than they have for any other
seven minutes this month i think that's
gonna happen but then i also think you
being
presented to the mass is like a lot of
people like oh that's dope and he can
sing what i'm saying for sure and if
they put it on their instagram that like
that kind of stuff it's when it lives on
the internet that's how you get them you
want it to be outside of your crowd like
right your crowd we got it for sure
we'll do a show this they'll watch this
we're trying to get it's like it's like
getting a write up in a it's a variety
yeah it's like you don't do that for
fans you do that for industry right so
it's like what i really hope happens
here too is that festival bookers and
people are like okay this kid's like
can has a chance at critical mass pop
culture
you know because right now i'm like the
[ __ ] rapper rocker country singer
that hangs out with nothing but
comedians and drinks himself to sleep
every night which is all true yes you
know what i'm saying chat chat chat
you nailed down like that he's speaking
of what's cheers brother i love it
you're in l.a i love you thank you for
just stopping your whole life like yeah
dude i've never potted at night but i'm
[ __ ] there i'm like it's gonna be
eight you were like whatever yeah for
you're the one guy i'd pulled off for
men you're the one guy i mean jimmy
kimmel dude big deal you're kind of huge
now you know i'm uh do you you don't
mike stud at all
oh of course yeah i love mike
mike's my boy he'll be out here uh shoot
next week but
he's a another guy similar to you where
he's been you know preaching independent
all the time and they've thrown some
bags and he's like i'm good i'm gonna
keep doing it myself
but you you signed with i did well i
worked out a really good partnership
with the company i just you know what i
had a moment of clarity for one
i can only talk about this so much
because of a non-disclosure agreement
you signed with daily wire right yeah
that's exactly how did you know
um
i kept i kept ownership of my masters
which is huge it's huge i kept a hundred
percent of my publishing still
i kept the lion's share
of the streaming revenue and i mean like
if this would be like a [ __ ] floyd
mayweather marquez fight one kind of
deal yeah like right that's probably the
most diplomatic way i can say it when i
get myself in trouble
so and so what's in it for them though
just well you
nothing can only be on their network i
was lucky that the president of the
company
just really believed in doing different
stuff that's cool so his thing was like
look i know i'm not going to make a lot
of money off you and that it's going to
be more than it's worth
but i he's into he's into legacy [ __ ]
yeah he's a dude that's like changing
the face of country music like this
record label is called broken bow
records
uh you all know nothing about country
music i'm sure but i'll give you the
briefing of it jason aldean chen knows
yeah i know the flagship is there huge
al dean's the big one but like jimmy
allen's one of their artists which is
like crushing you know a black dude that
dresses like a pimp and bowls every day
and it's like yeah not what you would
think it's like american idol yeah y'all
would y'all would love each other it's
like not what you think would be a
country artist blanco brown who had that
real big song put your hair down yeah
then who's that boo
took it number one at country radio
um laney wilson who's like this hippie
bell bottom wearing chick that sings
country music like their whole thing is
painting outside of the lines
like they don't want to be like hey give
me a big tall handsome dude with a
cowboy hat that grew up in cheyenne
wyoming with a big country song like
give me a dude that yeah yeah right yeah
they're like give me a dude that does
not look like he belongs here i think
that and let's make it work so i just
kind of lucky for me jonathan loba and
adrian meatball michaels were like
yeah dude we're into this different [ __ ]
because all these labels wanted to put
me in like pop they were like yo what if
we get you a song with charlie puth and
i was like i'm not interested i was like
i was like i want to play the grand ole
opry i'm from nashville yeah you know
what i mean like i want to you know
so finally and then i'd go to the record
labels and that's when they were like
hold on
you want us to take a dude with a
nickname a criminal record face tattoos
and permanent gold teeth and put out a
rock and roll or a country record
they're like get the [ __ ] out of here
and this dude was like yeah no problem
we're gonna take you straight where you
want to go there goes the granola for
debut damn it was incredible they did it
they told me they were going to do it
and they did it this is the record label
yeah yeah so it's like when they came in
i said look i just kind of like you i'm
like i've got
all of the i
make my own music write my own songs
produce my own records shoot my own
videos put my own content out i just
need you to give me the stuff that i
can't get as an independent correct
right
can you get me the radio yeah can you
get me to kimmel yep you know what i
mean like my publicist i got to publish
this for the first time my life
when i came to la
she couldn't book me nothing because i
booked myself yeah with the stuff i
wanted to do i was like yo
no no she's awesome though she did camel
right she's doing her job she's doing
great
so she's uh but she's like yo do you
want to do this and i was like oh no i'm
sorry if you you don't understand i'm
with the homies like yeah i'm like a
comedian in spirit i'm going to see shop
you hook me up with bird i'm gonna go
see burt you know what i'm saying i got
my own i got a circuit here i was like
i'll be all right i'm cool yeah with
those people i had a for my special i
was gonna hire a pr firm
and then i go okay what can you do for
me i'm like all right well tell us what
you already have and i gave them this
list i was like these are all my boys
that's what i have and what can you do
like we cannot beat that no there's
nothing these puppies are tough that way
like my manager like no matter what
ebooks what no matter what my agent
books they only get 10 percent of it but
they only get paid if i get that 90 you
know
whereas the publicist just takes five
grand and goes uh yeah we got nothing
for this month like what you didn't do
anything and i still got to pay you
they're like yeah it's that's different
thing yeah i said well i don't think
this is my thing yeah they got paid for
effort they get paid for effort they can
say well we really reached out to a lot
of people yeah they make you feel bad
nobody wanted you
[ __ ] i'm getting cold yeah i'd rather
pay my therapist can i ask a dumb
question to you of course where'd the
name jelly roll start oh this is a good
question my mother started i don't know
this yeah
my mother
i was a chunky kid and you know she
called me jelly roll and i spent the
last 35 years trying to grow into the
name yeah i think i've done her proud
what's life i'm just saying i don't
think i let her down at all even if you
don't know what it is you want a jelly
roll to be like i don't even know what
that is but yeah yeah
the cursiveness was i had to beat a
famous blues player a famous harmonica
player and the goddamn pastry on google
yeah how [ __ ] hard that was
jesus dude it was oh there was a there's
a famous harmonica player called jelly
roll johnson i've known about him
forever name he's clocking so sick and
he plays the hermit yeah so listen watch
here's the things the name jelly roll
johnson
and i met him at the grand ole opry last
saturday he doesn't look like a jelly
roll nah he's a pretty thin fella this
is back when he was a chunky monkey he's
a fall smaller guy now
but he's like crazy famous harmonica
really he's nice on the yeah
[ __ ]
jelly roll
yeah
he kicks ass up we got to hang out i
finally met him and i thought he was
going to hate me
yeah i was like this dude's going to
despise me because i'm sure he's like
you know the first thing he said was
like i get emails from your fans all the
time like talking [ __ ] no just like
you're not the realest
you want to grab lunch or something he's
like what
but he actually ended up being really
cool i don't think you're hateable in
any capacity yeah no you're very likable
you're approachable you're talented you
got a cool look i will say like this 40
years ago or something yeah probably
wouldn't have a lot of people
approaching you yeah that's a problem
but like in modern times like you're
like that's a guy yeah cool nice fun
drinks hangs
like the biggest guy in music probably
post malone yeah for sure tattoos always
right oh the best part my grandma would
go with uh is he safe yeah grandma he's
gonna be like you know like now teddy
swims came by the show last night i
don't know if you all know teddy but
yeah he's one of the best
on the [ __ ] really i'm gonna turn
incredible change your life yeah
incredible he's i don't want you to pull
him up well because he's my friend let
me see what he looks like
because he because he looks like me but
as far as like you know i thought he
said he had some titties
i'm into this titty swim yeah
he looks sweet yeah he looks like you
and post malone had a baby for sure yeah
but let me tell you something dude if
he's in a room right now he's a well i
call him my twin but if he's in here
singing
i'm leaving
he's very good of a singer he's such a
good singer really me and shin would
shut the [ __ ] up kind of songs that
we're talking about here r b everything
like he's just so soulful it's so good
oh man he's got that clip he's gonna
love him you know what pull up the clip
the one he just dropped that uh just a
small town girl i love it
i don't know i'm sure it was but it was
gonna hook you all up you got to get
them on the podcast
uh
was that look and that if he's just
talented you guys uh probably the top
right chin so he's just like doing um
yeah it's like him sitting in a place
with a piano i'm sure he's seeing him
with the trainer right here he's got a
big megan training record to tell right
now oh so he's already mastered yeah
tattooed on his face and [ __ ]
well let's hear a little bit
just the smile
he literally was just doing that uh
uh yeah yeah bernie the journey record
he's just he's just singing this in like
a subway or some [ __ ]
[Music]
why am i showing everybody this i just
lost every fan i had oh no no
oh
he took them
[Music]
all right what is he the best scene in
the world
he comes at a show last night and we're
just we're hanging and we were talking
about that like how you know he's tatted
up but he just has this big pop record
with mega trainer coming out
post malone like
there's a shift of that [ __ ] in the game
right now that's dope because i was
sitting there like just blackout drunk
last night yeah yeah we got drunk last
night so we're like blackout drunk at
troubadour after the show oh yeah yeah
for sure
yeah i was [ __ ] smacked i got smacked
what's today
anyways i got smacked the first night i
got here today's wednesday you're asking
the wrong guys it's tuesday's okay so
yeah yeah not to date it but whatever i
got here sunday night and we went so i
got drunk twice on sunday okay i gotta
share the story which is awesome i had a
six a.m flight and i got drunk on the
first flight nice i drank two margaritas
and five double vodkas and sodas i only
drink vodka that'd do it i got
[ __ ] sliced i mean completely
inebriated on the plane and it was like
the first time i had a flight attendant
that not only was like you know normally
they're like policing you yeah this dude
turned into a bartender he was like
twisted he was like making me drink
he's like doing a comedy routine for me
he saw me hiking [ __ ] well hey he's
trying to say your dick b
what are we splitting
i've been there man but also that's that
first class treatment yeah yeah
they let it the first time i flew first
class for an extended enough time for
them to get me drunk yeah and i was like
this is interesting so i landed drunk
and then when i sobered up enough i was
like i'm tired so then we just went to
the rainbow room we got drunk again nice
your girl was with you yeah yeah we went
and marched
we took it from the rainbow room to
saddle ranch oh damn yeah it was all day
ball
are you staying at the chateau
yeah yeah yeah oh damn yeah daddy yeah
we're having we made it
uh
died yeah really yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
that's what they say yeah yes
that's also where uh a lot of the videos
of uh biden jr yeah a lot of it's in the
chateau
yeah i bet uh our president biden haunts
that place now oh yeah yeah yeah
he's dead right and hillary clinton yeah
yeah he's dead she's dead right they did
i think they're all dead i don't know
yeah
there's some classic stories there man
boys get wild there yeah yeah blue she
died there
i wish you lived closer to me
yeah i'm getting drunk every night where
are you people just judge me you know
you're here
i need a guy to go get drunk with where
where do you live out here i live here
yeah i look close
yeah in nashville listen i never thought
i'd ever live in l.a until i came to
your studio today yeah it's nice when i
got off the exit i was like this isn't
l.a right this is like spring hill
tennessee yeah to me like when i think
of la i think of this like everyone
thinks of hollywood all that craziness
hollywood is dark actually where i live
in sherman oaks we had a bar that was
open every single night of the pandemic
including the lockdown and they're like
we don't believe in this [ __ ] we gotta
we gotta pay our mortgage and we'll take
whatever fine the city gives us and so
oh yeah oh wow it was dope though i got
covered from there yeah that's all right
it was awesome i was like i'll be fine
what's the place called and everybody's
so it was called the woodman but i have
a better bar right next to it it's a
diver called the chimney sweep which is
the best bar in the world in my opinion
there's a guy you want to go get drunk
tonight yeah dude i'm already going to
be the sweep anyways yeah he's
he's it yeah dude
i love
with jeff and we're driving back home
yeah i got kids man i need to be up at
[ __ ] 5 30. we're driving back and
he's like hey man we go to the bar i'm
like no and do what dude
he's a guy just drop me off got this
this is my favorite story about the
chimneys
uh me and my buddy william there very
funny comic comedian willie simon we're
there and this dude gets up and just
starts a fight just no reason walks over
to the table someone looked at him wrong
he just starts fighting this guy so they
get him out of there it's kind of
exciting we're all gossiping about that
it's pretty [ __ ] cool to see a fight
and then the next night we're there
again
same guy starts a fight with a different
dude another fist fight gets kicked out
this guy needs a therapist third night
in a row
the same guy has nobody to fight with so
he just attacks for no reason tries to
blindside the door guy the door guy's a
big guy so that they take care of that
they kick him out i say to the bartender
more i go maury
why why do you guys keep letting that
guy in he's gonna fight three nights in
a row she goes oh well you know he sells
drugs here
okay
that's also not allowed but now he's
protected bro this bar it sounds like
you you go to the always sunny in
philadelphia that's what it sounds like
it is a divey diving like there's
homeless people and then also you see
like hillary duff playing like darts
like it's like got all the whole gamut
of of the of life and the bartender's
poor whiskey like that big you pay like
four bucks you get away oh yeah that's
fine ellie's there i'm in i'll go
tonight you two are absolutely
do we have to pass there to get to
hollywood uh yeah actually yeah
sherman looks right there we'll swing
through and have some drinks on our way
to the rainbow room now does your
brother drink too oh yeah [ __ ] like a
fish he's probably out there stealing
[ __ ] my brother's probably out there
right now just stealing the bottles
you'd give us anyway just pocketing or
our cameras you guys yeah for sure no no
no no no we don't only steal drugs
did you guys grow up close yeah dude i'm
so close with my whole family really
yeah that's pretty sweet for sure it's
my older brother he's my middle really
we got one older i'm the baby we got one
older than him got him and i got an
older sister than me and they've all
supported you oh dude we've been cool
we've been as close as thickest thieves
our whole lives i'm so jealous of that
yeah that's so cool you know how rare
that is you know that's really rare yeah
i didn't realize that until yeah until
now not a lot of guys with facebook talk
about how much they love their whole
family oh dude we're great
we're all super white trash no but
that's so beautiful yeah i'm like
jealous a big old white trash bash
he's not like jealousy like he's [ __ ]
hilarious by the way he's the funniest
human on earth does he have any skills
as far as singing or anything no dude
he's literally just [ __ ] wild it just
[ __ ] has been in my whole life does
he work does he is he like
man no it's even crazier man i can't
afford him he he got into when he got
out of prison he got into
[ __ ] we all been unfortunately it's like
a family tradition let's talk about that
it's like it's like graduating college
yeah it's like oh you got your degree
too yeah three years yeah it's your
mormon mission he came home
he got into like engineering yo scott
yo scotty yo yo what do you call that
[ __ ] besides uh surveying you got a cool
word for it now
he does like lidar like what do you call
it civil engineering or something
he does like 3d so like ultimately he
surveys but he does the new style of it
like the lidar 3d imaging like yeah
drones and all that [ __ ] he's like to do
he can go if you get a piece of property
call my brother before you pay a survey
dude my brother will be the dude that'll
come out and be like yeah you're [ __ ]
that's swampland that's bad
because he's all tatted up and drunk
he's [ __ ] just like how long was he
and he'll sit here and do rails of coke
the size of that terra monopole he'll
[ __ ] be out here doing motley crue
lines of cocaine
yeah he's [ __ ]
he just got out of jail and was like
yeah i got to figure out what started
just surveying him you know he just
somehow got into what what put him in
the slammer
uh i think it was like an old drug case
or something yeah
that's so that's all that's not fair
drug stuff i mean come on man yeah then
he was like [ __ ] after like his third
or fourth time in jail i was young i'd
go visit him all the time so he came
home and got into [ __ ] like surveying
herself did you walk into jail when
you're visiting him like with the way
you walked in the studio like it's all
right maybe maybe we should have yeah
i was like yo my brother was here this
is all right this isn't bad yeah [ __ ] i
got friends for sure i'm a d4 and he
he's the oldest yeah well he's the
second oldest our oldest brothers in the
meat business like my father and this is
dope [ __ ] i never talk about no i love
it and did he also go to prison no he's
the only one who stayed kind of loser
yeah right [ __ ] losers
roger's actually the one who followed
our father's footsteps our father was in
the meat business and wholesale meat and
poultry and stuff we used to run a
sausage truck back in the day back when
the meat trucks would come to your house
yeah we're all
are you i don't know i think we're all
too young to remember but there was a
time where like
meat trucks would come to your house
like the milkman yeah like the milk yeah
and they pulled up to the neighborhood
it was like the ice cream truck
everybody knew the meat man was there
and you like
that it was little [ __ ] awesome right
[ __ ] post baits yeah so it's like he
turned into a wholesale business and
started doing independent barbecues and
[ __ ] like uh cb smith's buy rights
before walmart came and [ __ ] up all
you guys are pretty [ __ ] smart and
then what's the sister do uh the sister
is actually
got a master's in psychology and she's a
lunatic she doesn't do anything with it
but she she literally went and got a
master's degree to figure out herself
wow that's who she is as a human the
most me because we all grew up poor
enough that she could get a full ride to
any school for the whatever scholarship
yeah so she was like yeah [ __ ] i'll just
go figure this [ __ ] out and when you got
like a full degree in psychology because
she was like i'm just tired of being
crazy and there's nothing with it yeah
she just raises her daughter and [ __ ]
gets a chill well
yeah for sure yeah yeah she's a
full-time she's also really smart she's
the one i call when i want to laugh or
talk about real [ __ ] damn
that's not expensive because she's funny
as [ __ ] too yup no i got a wife [ __ ]
family yeah they don't know
white trash as they can be really i grew
up white trash and all my sisters we
have a drinking contest that same
brother in there once pissed on my
kitchen table at thanksgiving
oh yeah yeah we had a drinking contest
he got blackout drunk pulled his willy
out in front of the whole family
everybody
40 people thanksgiving dinner
turkey on the table and just let it ride
right there
no
no we tried to stop him he just wouldn't
stop he just kept pissing he's a bird
he's wow
dude i got a video hey if i send you the
video i gotta show you something okay
you're gonna have to why would you like
who
was my wife
like oh this is great that must not be
that long ago i pictured like you know
he was 10 years old
yes it was like it was the [ __ ] it
was the same day i hung out with y'all
thanksgiving from king in the states
that's right
the [ __ ] next day my brother blacked
out drunk and pissed all over
him
i'm gonna send you this video i swear to
god for this podcast
indigenous people you know he's mad at
thanksgiving so we're we're like a
competitive family so once we all
started drinking
between me him and our older brother you
know it normally turns into some [ __ ] i
feel like i feel like you've won
undefeated that's what dude when people
say oh i drink i'm telling you you don't
drink like jelly for sure
i've never seen a few times ago that i
was on this podcast we brought you up
because when we were all in nashville
like i'm gone and i'm pretty sure
drinking and he's already left the place
in you're still going around with shots
of tequila so i was gone you want
another one i'm going to probably
shouldn't be sure no you drank with me
but you were on the ropes yeah for sure
yeah we have we had to walk a straight
line to settle that bet i'm winning yeah
sure sure you're shaping what you walked
out and i walked out
i think you you're a big guy you know my
favorite thing was that night is the
next day uh uh lucas
um david lucas
he was on uh kill tony yeah and he was
like yeah i almost got kicked off my
flight this morning tony's like why is
that you ever heard of jelly roll
tony hitchcock's like no he's like yeah
he's like a country gangster guy
he's like anyways i drank with him with
like all the austin white trash rednecks
rooms like yeah yeah
yeah it was awesome i was like yeah i'm
posting it yeah that is fascinating
because like any time you're getting
kicked out of a plane for being too
drunk they're basically suggesting
you're too drunk to sit
you know you're just sitting there like
you're taking a pass i was not allowed
to get on a plane once
only time this happened in my life i was
coming out here to do
during super bowl weekend i was flying
out here in the morning
to do a um we were supposed to do the
fight the fight thing the caliber
that's right i forgot what fight it was
but it was super bowl weekend i was
coming i had a 6 a.m flight and i just
drank through the night
and i showed up too drunk and they
wouldn't let me they wouldn't even let
me check in though
so it wasn't like i couldn't sit down
that was i just [ __ ] myself i walked
in there like nobody cared it smelled
like weed i just like
i was literally i was on
i'm like fumbling for my phone i can't
find my idea i'm like can i just do the
thing because you know you can fly
without an id you just gotta go yeah you
go just go over there
with a costco car he's with me on the
road all the time he gets out his
costume
have you ever had to go through that
they put you through all the extra
security but i just finally i just like
i didn't want to go to the dmv you know
like but i finally did get it but it was
like six months it was like did they
ever do the quiz though like the one
time i did it they had a thing where you
could like they were like what car did
you own in 2008 i haven't had that they
give me the extra security and yeah i
asked them to do that when i couldn't
find my idea to come to the fight
i mean they knew i wasn't ready dude i
lost all faith in tsa mark has flown
several times with a costco id nothing
else in arizona we show up and i'm like
at the pool in the airbnb and i reach in
my portrait's pocket and pull out a gram
of cocaine i'm like oh this was in there
i said like i forgot about it oh my god
hold on let's tell the story yeah so he
he takes forever to catch he was gonna
miss the plane because they're i don't
know what the [ __ ] they're scanning them
they go through every single piece of
his luggage we get to the airbnb in
phoenix mark's being a you know crazy
ass and he's doing cartwheels by the
pool and he does a cartwheel and this
bag of cocaine falls out i go whoa dude
marco crazy goes coke
picks it up he picks up and i go and
he's like oh i forgot this i got this in
mexico like years ago i've been looking
for this
and then i go cool cool bro you realize
tsa went through every piece of your
luggage and didn't find any of this [ __ ]
yeah he's like yeah
yeah so we had to do it before we flew
back
it was you don't like mushrooms it
doesn't lose the thing i know that's a
long time ago but elvis used to uh elvis
used to just show up to the airports
with no identification be like i'm elvis
yeah and they would go
hey that's a fair point
so famous
you know to this day queen elizabeth
doesn't have a passport she travels all
around the world without any id that's
queen elizabeth makes sense
yeah like yeah it's fine yeah that's
pretty good listen have you all seen the
elvis movie yet yeah wait which one oh
then one of them came out
i'm going to see it sunday i want i yeah
the whole theater have you seen elvis
and nixon i went to graceland i played
graceland recently they had a concert
venue there and they took me on a
private tour after hours at night of
elvis graceland and i'd never been even
being from tennessee you been
no you i'm not the b i like i like
history and especially how big elvis was
elvis if there's a book that his manager
wrote before he passed away and you
realize that this man manager completely
[ __ ] elvis's career he was so selfish
made horrible decisions wouldn't let
elvis travel to do like huge
international tours because he didn't
have a passport so he turned it down and
forced him to do vegas and he knew like
elvis didn't do well if he was in the
same spot all the time so he forced him
to do vegas and that's when elves
started doing drugs and all this [ __ ]
because he hated being in vegas all the
time the guy really oh it's a dark dark
story yeah that's horrible but this dude
wrote this book about himself yeah
jesus
no there's a movie about elvis
he wanted to be able to fly with a
firearm because he's like a gun nut and
so he's like well the only way you can
fly is if you become a marshal or
whatever so he's like well who can make
me a marshal well you go to all this
school you could do all that [ __ ] or you
could just the president is another way
if he tells you he's well i'm so famous
i'll just meet with the president but
it's before his cell phone so he just
went and bought a hotel room by the
white house rolled up to white and said
i'm elvis i'm here to meet the president
and they're like
well you've got to have an appointment
he goes all right well just here's my
number in the hotel room i'll be at like
to have the president call and he just
sat by the phone for days drunk
and elvis
at the time nixon's like i'm not meeting
that punk-ass like yeah guy that shakes
his wiener around like i'm a real i
don't he didn't like celebrities and
stuff but his interns were like it might
be good you're up for re-election and
like
getting a photo with him it might help
and he was like nah i don't want to do
it and the the he goes all right five
minutes i'll give him five minutes after
weeks or a week of them trying to
convince him it's all in the movie they
he shows up in a cape
dressed like a jackass you know to meet
nixon who already hates him he's dressed
like evil elvis is so charming that the
meeting turned into like an hour-long
meeting and elvis convinced nixon that
like the beatles were these like
hippie ass punks that were coming to
infiltrate america and steal all their
girls and not be like americans and he's
right and nixon was like yeah yeah
you're right and so and he also did the
kata for him he did like this karate
thing yeah actually like he's a psycho
and he's awesome he became friends with
well i saw a great psycho yeah and so
then uh elvis
uh nixon made elvis on marshall just saw
him fly with guns
are you are you a big elvis fan well of
course i love a lot of his music but
i just didn't real i admittedly i didn't
realize how big he was man
until i went to grace i mean i knew he's
big he's elvis i get it
but it's like i know the business now so
i'm like walking through and they're
like they sold
50 million records in this record i'm
like
50 [ __ ] millions old zds yeah i'm
like what the [ __ ] dude it was
he was michael jackson uh yeah before
michael jackson i mean my mom gave me
all of her elvis records
i'm like how does one guy have hundreds
of records he did dude but like oh like
hundreds
no it's insane when you look at talk
about the us marshall thing he was like
giving a sheriff's badge in like every
city in america
they haven't hung up in like his like
his wardrobe case like his trophy case
you're such a savage i'd love to see
that movie yeah dude we're going to see
it the whole family's going we're
[ __ ] did you see the james brown
movie get on up yes yes [ __ ] yeah i love
that because he changed the game really
for entertainers who do live
uh stuff because he was the one like
hold up why do i need a promoter yeah i
was like why don't i just anything
didn't even be the hell out of a bunch
of women 100 oh yeah well hey beetle
that beat a lot of ladies
that part's not in the movie oh it's not
no he slaps
when i'm going through graceland i'm
like all right so where did he shoot
heroin and they were like excuse me mr
presley would have never done those kind
of drugs
yeah i was like didn't he die on the
[ __ ] with a needle in his arm they're
like this is all lies i was like i don't
like your personalized
yeah you know this is the lady giving me
the graceland tour i was like no lady
listen no did not bring me here to tell
me they wasn't snorting cocaine off of
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the jungle dude i
came to hear that
it's also like when you go to dallas and
they have the jfk like assassination
tour oh yeah mark was with me this i
think oh yeah my brother's in fort worth
right now uh built in dallas
he got shot from the library there but
uh there's a guy giving a tour i go hey
real quick where's like the realtor
no it's not dude
lee harvey oswald didn't do this the guy
did i went through because i yeah he did
i got my black button [ __ ] jfk i'm
like no dude come and i'm going through
all you say i don't know what you're
talking about yeah but that's not what
we do
i'm like no i get that but where can i
find that yeah like where's that guy
yeah he's out here taking my money so
where's the real real dude is this
have you guys been to paisley park
oh it's where the french was in
minnesota no or minneapolis not the
biggest prince fans oh so listen to this
i didn't know anything about friends so
i go to payson's park it's like a costco
it's like this big warehouse right and
they walk you through this dude
basically live there like be like if you
lived here and all you did was just make
podcasts and write jokes and you never
saw your family and they hated you know
every night people go to paisley park
and just buy ticket drink beer and if
and if he wasn't if he didn't come out
and perform they'd be like well we tried
we had beers at paisley park so he
always had an audience there was always
an audience if he wanted to come out and
play piano the truth is amazing but the
reason i'm bringing it up is because i
took the tour because i know nothing i
don't know nothing about prince so i'm
taking the tour it's like me and a bunch
of fat like minnesota tourists you know
like cameras around their neck like
sweet nice people midwest i go you don't
have to backtrack i've had shame too
better okay
picture of stereotypical tourists like
[ __ ] fat people was like very nice
minnesota people he's like that guy i
meant they were a fat shame they're
innocent you know their innocent beauty
is on the inside it's all good yeah yeah
so
as long as you're healthy
as long as you're happy inside they're
like innocent eared people is why i was
saying yeah and i'm like a loose slip
[ __ ] drunk comedian
i'm on the tour with a couple other
comics and we get to the part of the
tour where uh prince is making out with
a chick
in this movie that one of his movies
that he was in and i i said to the tour
guide i say uh oh man oh prince was into
like chicks
and they all gasped like oh
of course that's what reminded me they
were like of course prince was underwear
uh oh of course
crazy for assuming this dude's sweet
like
what i'm saying that's what i think he's
wearing glitter on his yeah you know
he's this big he's got high heels and
i'm crazy like a gay guy what he said
about the heels is the most gangster
[ __ ] on earth
they asked him with prince this is a
prince quote cause i [ __ ] with prince he
said uh
and i'll [ __ ] with this he said he said
why do you wear heels is it to make you
look taller he looked at that dude and
said women like heels
i was like [ __ ] swing that dick young
man
that dick young man but also yeah no
no
i might have been the straightest dude
in the world to [ __ ] the hottest one in
the world but don't think i'm crazy if i
know nothing about him for thinking
that's a gay dude yeah who's in crush
purple velvet all the time all the time
with crazy hair
all the stuff is scary i don't know
anything about him i go that's a gay guy
but he he was like a savant as far as
musically goes like
they were telling the story on saturday
night live
they put them on there it was like paul
mccartney just
and there was like it was superstars in
the music business and they wanted him
to do it and he was like yeah i'll do it
and then they were gonna get there was
something with paul mccartney and some
of these other big names wanted him to
do something like less time right and he
was like no that's not what i do and
they're like no that's the plan because
paul mccartney wants it like this and
here's how it's going to go and he went
okay i'll do that and then goes and was
like oh and it was knew it was live and
they said he ripped off like the hardest
like guitar solo ever yeah and like paul
mccartney everyone was like holy [ __ ]
and he walked off like yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah no he was a [ __ ] lunatic but he
was [ __ ] dope i went to i think it's
called first avenue it's like the spot
where they shot purple rain out we
played a show there one time but anytime
you go to minneapolis it's just [ __ ]
prince field it's all prince yeah one
thing is crazy is uh i had a buddy and i
don't know how reliable this is so what
i'm saying might not be even true but i
was told that there was this guy in l.a
he used to work for prince and he was
all about his legacy so he wants all
this [ __ ] to come out after he's dead so
like five years from now they'll release
like this prince thing that nobody's
ever seen some album that hasn't come
out yeah there's always like 1500 songs
yeah it's all banked or whatever but he
goes but the part about working for
prince he's got so much money and he's
so powerful and he's such this like uh
then he would just go i need a giraffe
by tomorrow and you're like i don't know
how much money in the world it takes
even if i have all the money how do you
get a giraffe by tomorrow like in
minneapolis but that's he would just
make them go figure out because you're
shooting all this crazy [ __ ] yeah he's
like [ __ ] figure it out he was always
making a movie i need a rhino and they
go i don't know how to get a rhino
where do you begin
he's got him he's got a dope legacy
though i respect oh yeah now did he pass
away from the sleeping stuff too yeah it
was some weird it's like the michael
jackson's i don't remember i think it
was a fentanyl yeah oh that's that jesus
before i was popular
he's in good company you know what i
hate about fentanyl is the go oh he
overdosed on drugs no no he was poisoned
yeah for sure because his plan was a big
difference maybe he was doing a party
yeah
yeah yeah if you took a viking or you
took whatever uh oxy yeah you know how
to control it he can do something he was
poisoned correct like like mac miller
was poisoned for sure i don't know why
he's tequila that's really like you know
a thousand shots in here or whatever
yeah and then if someone put fentanyl on
this i passed away like
his liver it's like he was an alcoholic
he died of alcohol
i feel like i could beat it you know
yeah
i don't think i can die yeah yeah
fentanyl is not [ __ ] up fentanyl is
the worst it's like you know yeah if i
died of a cocaine overdose that'd be you
know awesome
it's like dying no no not dying from it
you know what i mean it's like you know
also really hard to die from just
cocaine like uppers it's like i've done
a lot a lot of i've done a lot believe
your heart you wouldn't believe that
from a husky brian so brian
obviously the co-host finally kid he was
saying like once you reach your 40 or
around 40 he saw a lot of his friends or
a lot of people dying after cocaine
because their your heart can't handle it
anymore really yeah so that's why it's
dangerous i'm glad i got a few years
left yeah [ __ ]
gusto so his friends are yeah
you put turbo dandruff in there that
[ __ ] the heart well it's also like
let's let's talk about cocaine for that
that's right i got the worst cocaine
ever the other night at the [ __ ]
rainbow you did the worst cocaine ever
it would no
dude it's just you know when it's just
not it i know i don't you could smell it
oh you're missing out
it's like
you can't teach them this no i don't
dude i don't like cocaine i like the way
it smells yeah
you do not
try
listen man i don't like waiting for a
paycheck dude
get your paycheck up to two days early
with direct deposit you understand
that's more two days two more days to
save pay bills generally just feel good
about your money situation the chime is
more than just about getting paid early
it's also an award-winning mobile app so
easy checking accounts a debit card and
it's an optional savings account dude so
what are you waiting for hopefully not a
paycheck get started with chime today
applying for a free account takes less
than two minutes get started at dot com
slash fighter that's chime dot com slash
fighter c h i m e dot com slash fire
banking services and debit card provided
by the bank corp or stride bank n.a
members of fdic early access to direct
deposit funds depends on payer
dot com fighter
uh oh dude i love this new podcast
called business wars it's a podcast from
wandery that shares entertaining
eye-popping stories behind the world's
greatest business rivalries right newest
season of wondering oh my god business
wars four-part series hosted by david
brown ever heard of them yeah it was the
bitter feud between two fashion icons
gucci and louis vuitton oh my god
there's no better way to show off your
money status than by wearing a gucci
belt or louis vuitton shoe at first
glance these two companies have a lot in
common weight they start small family
owned making high quality luggage but as
their product lines grew they got more
popular the set listen these two
powerhouses were on a collision course
yeah man before long the rivalry would
devolve into family feuds as in like
hiring assassins to kill uh other people
that's how bad it was it was actually
boardroom battles runways backstabbing
oh yeah it was it was insane
gucci versus louis vuitton from business
wars on apple podcast amazon music
listen one week early and ad free by
joining one three plus in apple podcast
or the one reap uh that that story gucci
versus i can't believe they haven't done
a movie about me neither can't wait for
it it's insane my crew my crew carries
uh test kits
oh i don't know why more people don't i
mean
who's the nerd who's like hold on
we got a bus full of them that are like
yo
and i'm not like you know i mean i'll be
like my thing about drugs are i'll party
when it's like
you know it's like a party if there's
something to celebrate yeah it's like if
we're partying
right it's yeah yeah it's like if
there's like you know i'm not like hey
we're you know i think the doll's gotta
show yeah there's i think that dog's
dying yeah no he's been dying yeah yeah
that dog is awesome yeah the whole thing
i think does that mean he's got a poop
someone give him some cocaine yeah um
yeah
but the day of doing cocaine with a
stranger in the bathroom's over
yeah
there was a time in life you remember
this i'm sure yeah i mean you could just
bump into a stranger in a bathroom at a
bar and he'd be like you want to do some
blow and you'd be like i [ __ ] would
love to do some blow because that's the
unexpected blow right you didn't buy a
bag you didn't plan on doing coffee i
was in vegas
one time and you had like a grocery bag
full of it you know this is the memory
that i have where it's like yeah this
guy who i've never met before you know
my friend's coming over you got to kind
of give a heads up but yeah you know i'm
a [ __ ] for mustard you've never had
any dessert
for sure
last week i've never done coke either
and last week i'm uh there's this guy
that always gives all my friends coke in
los angeles and so i know him and he's
great guys he's a cool guy and he asks
me if he's just giving it away he's
super nice and rich and like he's but
he's kind of a scoundrel
he's like a fun mischievous guy i like
him
and so anyways i see him at this bar and
i haven't seen him for you know a long
time like what's up buddy he goes hey
man how you been that's comedy and then
i i'm walking past him coming out of the
bathroom and he's hey you want some coke
and i was like uh oh and then i go no no
no and then i go
like i'm with a group of friends and
i've never done it i go
what's the least amount i can do like
what's something i can like just try and
he goes
have you never done coke and i go no he
goes get the [ __ ] out of here like you
you wouldn't know what a whole guy was a
good guy yeah i was the polar opposite
like this is tonight's the night
it's like this is it i'm doing it i
don't do it much we should do it
together
i mean i was so like i walked by going
that he might have done a really nice
thing back there i don't but i don't
know how coke works but i would assume
you wouldn't want to invite me and mark
to a coke party with these noses no
listen you have a tiny nose yeah the
story's not hurt yes the stories i've
heard of mark i wouldn't want him in my
coke party
unless unless he was bringing the coke
it's like only if he's bringing if he's
the [ __ ] with the bag
anybody who references a cup my cocaine
story was real sims like yeah seen a
stranger in the bathroom he gave me a
bump he's like a [ __ ] from australia
with a grocery that's one of many so
you're like what the [ __ ] kind of
cocaine party
i would say mark's the animal from the
muppet babies
the coke monster man yeah you see the
animal you think you want him at your
party yeah and then when you have animal
your party
but cocaine's not a drug that you like
stop you know it's like yeah i've had
enough for tonight yeah for sure oh
really you just you know you're just
probably doing it you never have any
leftovers yeah it's not the drug unless
you forgot it was somewhere you don't
wake up like i'm glad we only did an
eight ball yeah quarter we got a whole
eight ball for today never yeah this is
last week's that's why i don't do it
sell it's got to be like you know like
we're i just have a song called
california i only do cocaine in
california yeah it's like it's got to be
that kind of thing for me yeah you know
it's got to be like a new york city
strip club like one of those pop-up
strip clubs and a bar yeah you know what
i mean not even like a rail strip club
where they set one up for the night
somewhere and you're like you end up at
it completely by accident and then
somebody's like i got some coke you're
like
i never plan on doing coke like i plan
on doing acid i plan on doing shrooms
cocaine is one thing i refuse to plan on
and i turn it down spontaneously 80 out
of 81 times and that one feels right
the crowd you might run into it right
like i said like but still i'll turn it
down more often than not so i'm like
yeah i'm gonna like [ __ ] gotta write
songs tomorrow bro i didn't see cocaine
literally i'm i'm a [ __ ] here i didn't
i didn't know people around cocaine so i
started doing comedy i'd be in a group
like wait why is everybody in the
bathroom
that way then i'm like oh everybody has
allergies
a big part of my life because i grew up
like church kid and [ __ ] like alcohol
was like i'm crazy i'm a drunk you know
but i like a guy could come up to me and
he'd act real strange and then leave and
i'd be like that guy's weird right like
dude that guy was blown out of his
brains but i i don't know how to
identify it i don't know brian oh no for
sure i tell i see it in your jaw your
eyes obviously you're like grinding
their teeth i'm in two seconds if
they're not grinding you just kind of
see it like this you'll just see a
twitch every now and then
and they do that kind of hit that real
quick
they're just like oh okay or they'll
lick their teeth
you know what i'm saying a little bit or
just come up with lipsticks and business
plans right for sure yeah yeah or like a
little eye twitch a little you know just
pupils will tell you if they're really
on blow
dude if you're scratching your nose
you're either on cocaine or a lower tab
for sure interesting you know what i
mean like 100 if i keep saying you hit
that number there i'm like what's up man
you doing blower [ __ ] thing mark does
a bunch of coke he's like dude you and
me are the only fans what are you
thinking yeah you would meet me right
now that's right
you're saying you do lsd right because
that's one that like you do and i'm kind
of like i'm good for a while yeah you
know i only do it like every drug i talk
about i talk about like i do it all the
time this is extremely rare for me yeah
but even lsd i'll do it like once or
twice a year and i and i'll go for it
though yeah like i when i trip i trip
like i'm not i'm not here to play with
it like we're doing three four hits and
we're [ __ ] going and i feel like
you're meeting some demons oh dude yes
or i'm having the best night ever
normally i'm just having a great night
though it's fun yeah yeah bad trips
though i've learned what i've learned
acids different shrooms you can kind of
level your trip out anyways i love
shrimp right it's like i can take
shrooms and if it starts getting weird i
can be like re-center myself in the
earth like if i'm at a party and [ __ ]
gets weird i'm like it's like the
environment go outside staying on the
grass barefooted for a minute you'll get
your [ __ ] back together acid sometimes
you don't know what's happening that's
what i love about it i love the crap
shoot of drugs right when you're just
like all right y'all i put six hits of
acid in this bottle of water we're all
gonna take sips until the water's gone
and then we're just we're gonna figure
out what happens
we're gonna lose our [ __ ] together we
are no longer in control of the night
dudes
well you let me tell you one thing about
acid
uh
no the last thing you want to do on lsd
is pull your pecker out really yeah yeah
for sure you have a whole like
a different understanding of that
anyways like any time i've been around a
girl and i started tripping to answer i
would look at them unnecessarily be like
i'm not [ __ ] you tonight i feel like
that was mushrooms that's why i clear
that up right now i have like no like
but doesn't coke too give you a olympic
but you want it but you still want it is
like i feel connected to life in the
universe
that sounds like torture yeah just
disappointing a woman that's the
opposite of molly where you're like
horny and the wind blows you're like
hello little fella good to see you
here we go calm down we're still at the
bar
that was just a gust of wind
dude i had this uh the only time
it's not molly was it uh mh uh mdma yes
that's still yeah that's still ecstasy
though yeah is it oh it sounds like a
real pure form so our buddy was this
real i won't say him but he's super rich
dude like super successful and he loved
fires that time i was fighting me all my
fighter boys go over there and he told
us there's a bunch of there's going to
be a bunch of chicks and get all this
food i'm going to do [ __ ] whatever
what is it
and i'm like yeah what let's do it man
so we get there and he's like yeah it's
getting a hot tub like yeah turn that
[ __ ] on
and then we're taking the mda and we're
there and like 30 minutes goes well i
never forget my brother who's got you
know quiet inserious
[ __ ] all the chicks
no he was like hey man we should wrestle
and we started wrestling dude
and then my brother would i'll never
forget because he lived like two blocks
down we're driving he goes
hey that was weird right yeah
he goes yeah dude
you might not know him
you want to touch people like that's
what you often when i take it with my
girl it's just like you kind of end up
like just touching each other for hours
and yeah you know i don't know so i can
i can see why he probably just wanted to
[ __ ] touch you because yeah i want to
fight this fighter
where the [ __ ] are all the girls
he wanted to touch something i realized
everything there had a pecker on it yeah
hot tub
jeff what about you have you done lsd no
never i'm actually new to mushrooms but
i all these other things i've done
mushrooms yeah
just like let's drink beer and yeah i
like i love drinking every night yeah
but uh i've done i did mushrooms the
last two nights in a row and i did so
much the night before last that last
night it didn't work
i took a fistful okay it just didn't
even affect me it dropped when you take
it night after night it drops off yeah
because the chemical or whatever has
already drained you sensitized to it
pretty good for sure so sucked i sat
there i eat a ton of mushrooms and like
i barely felt it but man lsd you might
be able to take and get it
i love it man i'm funnier than i've ever
been in my life when i'm on mushrooms
yeah i love it yeah and alcohol is my
thing but like mushrooms is my new thing
hey hey mark is your hat say heisman it
says heisman yeah it's like a drug ad uh
yeah well if it's ricky uh isn't it
ricky williams company heisman i don't
know it makes sense though
these dudes hooked me up they sent me
this gear and then they were like hey we
want to send you some weed and uh we
can't like send it to you but i just
went to uh a dispenser
uh
yes yes years ago yeah he's awesome yeah
he's cool yeah yeah good dude really he
sees like michael jackson where you can
like you can actually monitor through
his career when his voice changed he
used to talk normal and then now he's
like he's the one that just took his
wife last night
i don't think so that's a different guy
yeah and this is ricky williams brad i
just looked it up i just wanted to make
sure what's gonna take his wife's last
name yeah i'm so this is what happened i
shouldn't be on pocket no you know ricky
this is
maybe he did take his wife's name i'm
telling you dogs somebody else
is an american football running back who
played 11th season why does he say that
i don't know
oh when you're hungry hold on just go
back nfl
go backwards
because it's on there if you go to the
news
uh
uh no yeah no
listen so i don't sound like a dumbass
just type in football player takes
wife's name or x football player
swear to god this happened now ricky was
a dude who's a monster and they're just
dipped out yeah and like thank you for
this he's on the podcast you're saying
he dipped out and like went to africa or
like brazil was just living in a tent
well he also like i don't know how many
woods i go to brazil
gabe barrels
i'm feeling like a dumbass right now i
swear to god i just seen this the other
day it was like some dude was like took
his wife's name go back to his wife
on his spouse i don't know
uh man changes his uh last name to wives
yeah man changes i hate that term
yeah whatever whatever
i mean i didn't know you were [ __ ]
you know
uh i didn't know george jung from blow i
would have had some [ __ ]
devil's damage for you i didn't
well i'm not
just not seeing anything man wikipedia
page just showed his spouse's name and
if those match it makes sense because it
said eric mirren or something yeah i
can't believe this article isn't i just
seen it at the other douse completely so
if it was him it would definitely be
[ __ ] news
is dope man 2021 he made some sort of
deal
what's that
when a man takes his life no that's just
by the way it was like a real famous
football player i was like that's
interesting yeah
i don't know i think it was current i
think it was like an action kaepernick
yeah it's weird
it's weird that he'd play in the nfl and
be a [ __ ]
no i don't know how that works man
that's tough i mean just go to ricky
williams wikipedia oh get in there go
there you go [ __ ] tall joe there you
go
i was like yo i know i'm not tripping
here you know how much weed you got to
smoke to sit there one day and be like
yo [ __ ] let's go back we should like
cause some [ __ ] out [ __ ] i'd be a
mire and i think your family's cool i
like your [ __ ] mom do you mind my
girl like absolutely not oh perfect i
was like hey i'm gonna change my name
yeah it's probably because he cheated on
her so much she's like all right i gotta
give her one oh
he cheats a lot
right yeah my mother's pretty public
yeah i had a baby with a couple of them
yeah injection calls for speculation
that'll do it yeah because you guys i
gotta give her some uh that's a that
might be the move yeah go hey how about
i take your name i shot a chance
on his wife you know kobe cheated on his
wife allegedly raped and then he goes
how about i change my number
yeah
how about i go
from eight to twenty i'm not raping
anymore i'm 24. that was all eight
yeah yeah stop dead numbering me yeah
yeah ricky's all day what are you
talking about ricky
you think his wife is gone well he
changed his number
what more do you want him to do
but with ricky's like you're talking
about the old ricky this is aaron or
whatever the [ __ ] are they mirroring
yeah i can't believe that ricky guy
that was a real scumbag [ __ ] eric
mirren now
he uh but he's a sweet guy in that way
that like there was something i'm gonna
botch it a little bit and i'll get beat
up in the comments here but there was
something where he was like well i don't
think i should just get this contract
how about if i get this many run this
many touchdowns you give me this much
money and if i get this many touchdowns
i get this much money he's such a and
then he got like injured or he did he
under achieved yeah and so then he made
this really small contract and
everyone's like what the [ __ ] and it is
like that's kind of honorable actually
yeah pretty dope yeah i mean he he made
a lot of money though he did a lot of
things like that where he's like just a
sweet guy he like values kindness well i
mean if he sent mark [ __ ] weed hats i
think that's awesome yeah yeah i don't
know
and sent me some clothes and then hooked
me up with a bunch of weed so you know
yeah you're not a big weed guy though
anybody no but i like to have it around
like once a month or so he likes free
stuff
that is true like i ca i have a you know
anybody who reaches out it's like
yeah all drugs are way better when
they're free absolutely yeah i agree
yeah so so jelly uh going back to your
music signing with this uh
this big record company obviously jimmy
kimmel's a big deal yes sir and then
we've got a number one on
on rock radio for two weeks consecutive
we're still in the top 10. we're the
second most played song on rock radio
this year jesus christ of every rock
song that came out this year do you give
credit to the
100 because i knew that was out of my
realm of like you know
[ __ ] you know the way i was working
was independent like you like what was i
gonna do like email [ __ ] jimmy kimmel
like hey
i sing pretty well be really awesome if
you let me come do it one day yeah they
tell you no i've been there when you say
independent so that does that mean you
don't have a manager or agent or just
not only it's like we still have a team
yeah but the team could reach out to
jimmy kimmel and say hey this guy's the
best yeah
they scratch each other's back they're
not going to let a guy on who's not in
the system
because in comedy it's like
you just submit and they go oh he's good
enough
yes and no right like if you're just
like a guy that nobody like you have no
like steam behind you they're not going
to book just it's not a label
way more political music because one you
don't have to clear jokes
right i want you to think about this
like
you have to clear it it's in like it was
your material with criticism it's
appropriate or whatever exactly but no i
meant like we got a clear like the dude
who played the fiddle on the song that
gets played on saturday night live had
to sign off that that artist could
perform that song
so you break that down into [ __ ] 12
people that have a hand in a song just
all the hurdles that come with music
licensing it
like y'all are one autographed sign-offs
you're like yo i'm not going to say
anything dirty and i wrote this and i'll
sign the sheet of paper promise i want
to say the n-word
yeah you're in you know where for us
it's like okay who owns the publishing
on this who owns the master recording on
this what label has a piece of this yeah
it's so hard to clear
uh mike stud was on busting with the
boys shout out to the boys
friends of ours of course big time yes
mike still was on bus with the boys and
he was talking about a record he has
with post malone
hillary posts are really good friends
yes and it's like you know he's he would
have to play ball with the major label
to get the record released
and it would ultimately it's going to
take and he'll get the record release
but it's ultimately going to take post
malone calling the label himself and
going
i want to do this and if you don't do
this i'm going to be upset and post has
that power he does because of who he is
correct the label and what the record
sounds and all that for sure but even
then
the label is going to be hard to say
well he can only release it between
these two projects and
you know whatever so it really turns
into like a hula hoop of a job well i
guess the question is it's for comics
podcasters and musicians it's like
is the juice worth the squeeze you know
what i'm saying like what's your angle
jelly you know yeah well my goal seems
to work out for you yeah for sure my
goal was always i think my music's
cathartic i think my music's therapeutic
and i make music with the intentions of
it helping people that's my goal
so i need ears on it i've already made
good money i'm already blessed i'm
already in a great place
now it's like how can we legacy right
what can i do to touch more people how
can i bring people that need to hear
this message to this message yes in a
broader spectrum audience right and
that's where the label would have so
it's like country music's radio audience
as an example
is like 40 million people if you're in
the top five
like it's still that big of a deal to be
on country radio oh bro look what the
look what uh you know what different
morgan wallet for sure absolutely
councilman country music event holding
no fans like hold up country music fans
are the best fans
they're the best fans on earth so it's
like rock radio still touches x amount
of millions of people it's like you have
such a reach through radio
and then popular
like pop culture like it's still the
look of having the chance to do kimmel
and what you hope is
ultimately leads to something like
saturday night live which is still
extremely relevant right that's like the
creme de la creme for an artist if you
play saturday night live more
importantly if you can host
saturday night live that's like a really
big deal you know and you also hope that
people find out you're a good dude you
make relationships in the background
like
mgk is a great example of a dude who
ended up doing movies with it and
you know that dude really took that [ __ ]
from being like an underground white boy
rapper to like
[ __ ] co-headlining bonnaroo the other
day yeah he's another level yeah he's
just his new documentary dating
insane documentary is nuts he's dating
one of the most famous women on earth
his producers dating his best friend
travis is dating one of the other most
famous women on earth his other best
friend pete davidson is dating the most
famous woman on earth yeah it's like
those and those dudes are like they're
all shout out to all them they're all
friends of mine yeah they're all [ __ ]
regular dudes who just worked their
craft figured it out found a way in the
pop culture in their own way yeah and
went forward so my thing was like how
can i get this message
to people like i think save me
could help people come off drugs i think
save me could help people deal with the
loss of a loved one yeah don't play it
from either right yeah like yeah for
sure you're not on drugs you alcoholic
my goal is to turn you into a coke head
and i'm going to work vigorously at it
now you ever get some not that it
matters i mean everyone deals with it
rogan dealt with this went to the
spotify deal you know i'm sure other
artists deal with if mike stud signed
with a record company people
you hear this from people that blow up
all the time oh you sold out you know
luckily
i haven't i mean i'm sure it's there
but i haven't heard it so it's like i'm
sure it's gonna come and i'm fine with
that it's like listen
my thing about the word selling out is
i've never seen it used except for when
people call you that in a bad way in a
bad way
what do you mean like think about the
term selling out like
tell me where that's bad
except unless you're the guy trying to
buy the m ms that are sold out at the
store right it's like supposed to get to
a concert you can't get into it think
about it whatever think about
oh my god you came so popular some huge
brand paid you millions of dollars for
your talents yeah what i was here is
you've changed right yeah no [ __ ] yeah
my favorite line from nelly was they
said nelly you sell out you're damn
right i don't sold out the phone came
back the same night it's like you know
if you tell me my show is sold out
it's the best news you can call me with
the single best news you can get on
earth is hey sold out show one putting
up two nothing better
sold out show too you gotta do a
saturday you're like [ __ ] yeah yeah
people it's like when you use this term
of like you're selling out it's like god
i hope so
i hope you came in uh merch just said
mainstream sellout first like he leaned
into it here's a song called mainstream
sellout for sure yeah
no she didn't compromise i guess would
be like the main thing that people like
for sure
you change somehow but if you don't do
that then you're just making money my
poor message is the same i'm not making
music to be commercially viable i i sung
son of a center on jimmy kimmel today
like it is a [ __ ] heart-wrenching
real song about the duality of life the
third verse says um
uh my pop appeal is smoking maybe drink
i'll talk to god and tell him what i
think at first he's gonna hate me but
eventually he'll save me right we're
talking about like i that's the song i
sung on kimmel
like i wasn't on there you know
pop it for me baby pop it from me baby
you know what i'm saying like i stay
true to my core message of who i want to
touch like
as long as i don't compromise that i
think i'm okay you know what but i think
it's it's this thing where it's like if
like uh people say this against uh blink
182 all the time travis uh bart's wife
close love travis yeah and he's actually
in the hospital right now hopefully he's
okay but uh
you know blink way too blew the [ __ ] up
but there was like this small demo in
orange county or whatever where they
think they discovered them as they get
bigger they get jealous right it's like
you guys sold out and like just envious
people love our music right like what do
you want to do yeah
i think i'm blessed that jelly roll fans
and this is listen i i bet i bet money
would say this in a comment
i think i'm blessed that jelly roll fans
feel more like
they their right to feel this way they
are responsible for it they're proud of
you yeah so instead of feeling like [ __ ]
man dude don't get big on us i remember
when you was a nobody they're like yeah
[ __ ] we bet on the right horse
yes we knew you had us you haven't let
us down those are the fans you want
these the real fans appreciate like
you're come up one cause like oh i
remember when that dude was doing this
yeah for sure it's like to me i think me
being on national television singing a
song is like for an entire culture it's
a voice of the voiceless yeah there's an
entire unspoken audience of people who
are like our dude yeah is on jimmy
kimmel they might not agree with the
station they might not agree with the
politics they might not agree with the
monologue they might not agree with all
the [ __ ] that comes with being on this
television
right yeah but there's a moment where
they're like i don't care that's our
dude saying our message yeah you know
what i'm saying like that's our dude
speaking for us like [ __ ] that's our guy
yeah they should celebrate that now
after you got done singing did jimmy go
now can you put your mask back on yeah
you know i'll be honest i was the only
person in there all day they never said
nothing about a mask good they made my
brother put his mask on at one point but
they never that's that first class
treatment yeah for sure i don't know it
was because i was the artist there today
or because i just walked around like the
kind of guy that you might not want to
walk up to like yo
why game with you in nashville and it
was funny because in naturally i roll up
i'm with terry bradshaw and we're going
to do this all day we were there stadium
like super early
you when you showed up there was like
this like
happening there jelly roll is coming
like everybody was like talking about
how like yeah i'm like i'm with terry
bradshaw
you're like jelly roll i was like i
haven't met jelly roll like jelly roll's
coming like there was like a hole i sent
your youtube to somebody you have over
two million subscribers and you and
people don't conceptualize how difficult
that is to build oh my god youtube with
two followers some of the views i mean
some of the views on there yeah over
independently you know it's it's insane
no it's it's still it's it's unreal it's
like but think about what you're doing
so [ __ ] dope think about your boy tom
mcdonald yes for sure you want to talk
about independence yeah you know that we
talked about
yeah he's he's really impressed it's
literally all independent his girlfriend
what he
he's so is and scary yes i call him
sometimes like i [ __ ] hate you
i get a lot of trouble
teddy because teddy's so great i'm like
teddy i love you but [ __ ] you tom is so
independent i was like i want to support
this guy i went to this merch i was like
this is way too intense yeah you have
anything else
i [ __ ] ate that guy i'm like you
should be taking notes though for sure
because
he could be singing the worst music in
the world i don't give a [ __ ] hey he's
super talented but b it's just i
appreciate the hustle of him doing on
his own and just the way he's revamping
the game for sure comics could learn
from him because he'll drop an album and
then he'll package it with merch yeah
bro he should be on billboard it's the
number one selling album i've ever heard
of last year
yeah i tell you something artists could
learn from comics right quick first of
all tom's the homie dear good friend
remember i hope y'all love that's my boy
i love that dude is the sweetest dude on
earth and he's a great songwriter like
he does the he's also really political
commentary stuff such a nice yeah but
he's also like when you get to like the
quarters he wrote a song called scars
that came out two weeks ago and i called
him and i was like yo i thought i'd text
and i was like bubba
i love that you can rap and that you
like have these real rare ways of like
putting together
social commentary and rhythmic form and
making people think about [ __ ]
but this is a [ __ ] song bubba like
i'm like banging scars like it just made
the playlist like it's [ __ ] good like
that like that dude can write the mother
yeah absolute [ __ ] he wouldn't make it
if he wasn't so talented you know what
like he'd be canceled so fast he was
just gonna be independent no he's not
one no he did like a very like uh i
don't say
like political but like in the height of
like lockdowns and like you know he
talked about some touchy issues but it's
so brilliant whether you agree with it
or not you're like yeah yeah
he can make a point but then he does
he'll he'll drop a political song and
then the next song is like a song like
ukraine had it coming or like what is it
well
like what do you mean something i love
the old school comic of jeff he's like
who can i have been i don't know what
can i say
no just the last bro he's also it's like
hot tub time machine it's like you came
from the 90s yeah for sure yeah i know
yeah no he's richard pryor on the sunset
strip yeah yeah [ __ ] follow us
just political music right no but he
will he'll do something divisive but
then we'll just bring up his youtube
channel
you know the cool thing is he'd clear
him we could play whatever here and i'll
be like yo white list this on this
[ __ ] shop podcast yeah i mean him he
really owns a [ __ ] like that yeah i mean
him we're texting each other he's such a
nice guy
so it's like you know the system that's
gonna get dicey for you
fake woke yeah the scars one's the one i
was just talking about that one down
there that's a 9.6 that's my best friend
struggle me and struggle have been best
friends for 20 years literally we went
to jail together we've been through it
all
him and uh adam calhoun they're all good
friends of mine these dudes are [ __ ]
look at that 7.7 million views
oh yeah two weeks ago stars 3.1 million
he sells more albums than the weekend
he's good and he went to a billboard he
had he had this whole youtube he went to
billboard it was like yo what do i have
to get this they told him to do all this
stuff he does all of it and he goes i'll
give you access to all my sales
everything i can prove i've outsold the
weekend and the billboard still wouldn't
touch him really no it's ridiculous
specifically i think he was like i don't
have an issue with billboard i have an
uh issue with the company that audits
the same like that was specific that's
what he was doing yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah we don't make it seem like he's
talking about it
bro so his the clown world 60 million
views yeah the cancelled one 15 million
views no everything he does fake woke 28
million views he figures it and whether
you agree with his con his content or
not he's really no lives matter was a
big one yeah for sure he's really
strategic about what he does and all
these videos he like shoots him in his
living room yeah really no they built
him and his girlfriend bill said shout
out to nova they build sets in their
house
comics should learn like his marketing
and [ __ ] and the way he does it all in
the penny is not so yeah yo let's talk
about comedians that do that yeah right
that are [ __ ] i take notes from these
guys
shoals
chelsea's you yeah the way you built
this business right
i'll start with schultzy's right so
schultzy
[ __ ]
i'll give you an example of what i
thought was genius when he played la
right
and he rented the 64 hopper yeah right
just just for the content footage of
pulling up to the sold out theater in
l.a in this [ __ ] night he took it to
another level because his production is
not like when he did dallas he's like
it's like this building right when i
walk in this building and i tell people
this all the time like especially
whenever i bump into the occasional shob
skeptic
i'm like y'all don't understand how much
this dude bets on himself though oh yeah
he's not just talking [ __ ] like and even
coming in here i've seen every one of
these sets individually and i knew you'd
put the time into it but when i pull up
in [ __ ] calabasas which is a place
i've been rapping about before i knew it
was here because i just knew it was
fancy
right and i see thick boys studios on
the sign
right and there's only two names on the
side of a huge building you know what
i'm saying yeah and there's little stuff
i'm like he just [ __ ] does it right
yeah you know what i mean like when you
walk in and you see everything in every
wall and the
attention to every detail you put in
[ __ ] having whiskey cubes of ice
instead of regular eyes yes sir the fact
that you got the whiskey glasses with
the one big cute little things that i'm
just like
[ __ ] yes like
little things that just makes you go he
thought every part of this now jelly
this place is cool right now when you
get to bert bert house tomorrow you get
a burt crasher's new house tomorrow
so
i haven't done this podcast i don't know
three four years because the pandemic
all that [ __ ] so when i was promoting my
special you know at my ferrari i called
burton his last house was a little dicey
north hollywood i call him i go hey man
i know i'm supposed to do the podcast
tomorrow i i got i'm in my friday shoot
this thing yeah can he just open the
gate so i can park in the actual thing
because i don't want someone to jack my
[ __ ] and he goes oh no i moved dude
trust me you're okay all right send me a
new address yeah he sent me address i
was like all right whatever i trust bert
you're gonna get there tomorrow and
you're like oh there are levels to this
thing oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
i don't think people realize how big
bert is oh like i'll have even comics
even brian has burnt chills tickets
bit that bit that he didn't want to put
out that rogan talked him into that that
bit has like i don't know 400 million
views oh dude
universal shot of feature
film yeah on it well during the pandemic
thousands of people were willing to
watch him from their cars that like
driving
i mean that's listen let me tell y'all
tough to do god has blessed me that we
do really well on tour
bert kreicher is playing just got
through playing the same
aaa baseball fields
minor league baseball stadiums and
amphitheaters that i'm playing this year
and selling them out in hours i'm
talking about ten thousand
twelve thousand capacity football
baseball stadiums i'm talking about
eight to fifteen thousand person sheds i
know it was the fully loaded tour and he
had david telling all these legends on
this tour no he's doing that without it
but ultimately
i don't care what your package is when
you're anchoring it down and it was your
your dream child that dude came to
nashville sold out the ryman and the
grand ole opry back to back and i don't
know if we did two shows to ramen or not
but that's 2400 at one and 48 at the
other i think thirty-five
tonight is super normal right
right we're talking about yeah i i
i'm a huge bird fan
and
you know comics is just weird jealousy
thing but if bird doesn't inspire you
what he's doing like business-wise for
sure and he's such a good person he's
another one he's so excited she's
showing me how to make [ __ ] look big he
invents he knows how to package and
produce [ __ ]
bert taught me how to sell tickets
that dude there's nobody better than a
[ __ ] 40 grand on a pr on a promo
for a tour right just [ __ ] he's not
afraid to burst a guy you can talk about
like i i would whenever i have questions
about tickets especially inflation right
now so bert is a mastermind if you talk
about tickets bert will tell you hey if
you raise it five dollars this is what
happens your sales is it ten dollars
this is what happens your sales he's
brilliant no for sure he he does clean
sellouts he sells off the single seats
he taught me how to [ __ ] sell the
tickets
[ __ ] gillis shane shane's a monster
he's [ __ ] crushing dude the way his
whole approach
to youtube and the skits and [ __ ] that
hillary clinton
these are dudes you watch uh stav
stavros is that how you say his name
yeah he just released his uh special on
on youtube yeah
he's [ __ ] hilarious his uh special is
really good
but he's also just really like the way
he's putting up clips constantly he's
like filming every night in the comedy
you're doing the same thing i'm watching
on the road yeah dude you're filming
every night it'd just be some crowd work
yeah some funny [ __ ]
man it's like dude rappers
country singers rock and roll artists
need to be studying this [ __ ] because we
are missing the [ __ ] mark yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] so inspiring to watch the
way comedy is like having it's [ __ ]
it's going to be bigger than it's it's
got to be bigger right now than it's
ever been well because now it's more
competitive you talk about this job it's
like now it's so competitive as far as
like
you know even you know when i first
started like eight years ago i'd go into
town it's like there were big headliners
but now it's because the podcast like
dude you're competing against a lot of
different comments now man well the fans
are not fans audience members regular
people whatever you want to call them
like they're more aware of stand-up
right yes you'll hear them talking about
things you're like how like even that
guy you just brought up it's like i'm in
the industry i don't know this guy i
knew him from come town though and
people and people are going oh yeah you
know like you know you've heard of and
you're like there's more comedy nerds
now i remember when i first started
stand up people i'd go who's your
favorite stand-up community and they go
uh seinfeld yeah and you go have you
seen steinfeld stand up they're like no
but i love the show yeah they just know
he's a comic right they'd know like
eddie murphy but they didn't even know
his stand-up like where it's now it's
like they're pretty in touch it's also
interesting like i'll do you know i have
shows that the laugh factor on thursday
i'll go there and there's comics i've
never heard of my watch or sam like holy
right this dude or female is a
monster right like having been doing it
eight years
you know and then i'll be like how have
you not like and there's like they
either they're really about the
marketing or they've just had bad breaks
or there's there's something missing or
they're just waiting and they'll be the
next big thing or the cool thing about
y'all's business is though that's
different than ours is dude they might
have just been spending eight years
figuring that [ __ ] out in the clubs
privately for sure eight years ago they
might have sucked dick yes right you
know what i'm saying it's like eight
years later you're like you're [ __ ]
killed it's like you should have seen me
two years ago i was in here getting
booed yeah i was saying it's like i
[ __ ] found my voice and figured it
out y'all [ __ ] is so different like that
than us because it's like
we sit privately package something and
then present it to everybody where y'all
go work it in front of everybody
it's a wild could you imagine me like
sitting on stage like hey y'all trying
this i wrote this song in the green room
what do you think
like [ __ ] boo yeah they save me or
leave fat ass
son of a center [ __ ] yeah you know what
i'm saying the classics right like for
certain songs like if
as a comic you did i mean bert does the
machine story still but it's very rare
you get a comic you know and i think
some people want it like seinfeld does
that jay leno does that like the
classics but in general like it's so
competitive now if you're a younger
comic yeah you're doing old jokes that
are special or clip people saying they
like get the [ __ ] out yeah and then like
it looks like a standard now it reveals
what we do too yeah we've
lifted the curtain so now it's like well
we thought that i mean they don't think
this but they sort of think that we're
just coming up with it off the yeah but
they they know we don't but they also
like but when they see you two times in
a row and they see they then they go oh
yeah this is just
it's not as magical oh no i've had some
people come to show them like yeah i'm
about taking the next one is it all new
i'm like no you think i do a brand new
hour for every show
i will say watching your set develop is
something i got to do where i watched
you in the pandemic come with new
materials yeah to zane he's like 20 20
pandas
and then i watched gringo poppy and of
course i'd seen you right before that
yep back in nashville
and it was still from 2020 to 2021 or
whatever late 21 22 whenever i seen you
totally different set almost there was
like maybe two or three things that made
it the first 45 minutes i've seen and
then even from that to you finalizing
the product and going this is what i'm
putting out was still like there was
[ __ ] i think it was like you did like
a
41 minute special a little bit over 40
minutes or 30 some minutes yep and there
was still like 20 something minutes of
new laughs for me yep and i've been
watching this show development
i see it every time you come to the city
i come to multiple shows i watch one
drunk once sober yeah i mean it's like i
come to one and party and i'll always
come to second night and watch the early
show because i [ __ ] got loaded in the
second show over anything that happened
that's why that's why with the
the the like green room diaries where
whatever city is the first you know five
to ten minutes is jokes just for them
it's never getting done again i'm
writing it the week of the before i get
into town right that's just for them no
that's so [ __ ] dope but i just think
it's cool to watch i've always admired
comedians and i always tell people i'll
be a comic when i grow up
whenever i get tired of writing songs
because you got to always have something
that's next right or you'll get
something i feel like you're just
getting started like jelly like
if you get mainstream like that's what
you want you know what i'm saying that's
like you want that post malone vibe yeah
well it's like it's more than it's just
i just want to touch people man i just
want to get you know
if i didn't think the music and i'm not
just this isn't like my gimmick this is
like
i like you i own my ip i own my masters
i could sell my catalog today
buy a house on mulholland drive yeah and
just [ __ ] fade to black and drink
myself to death whether it took five
years or 15 i could just go into a yeah
just come hang out whenever i want to
i'll come pod for fun once every three
months i'll come out of my little hidden
hills estate and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah it's like yeah it's like i don't
even
i'm past this for being this is like i
want to touch people yeah i know how
much
saved me or son of a dude i get messages
just like we all do from fans are like
yo
i got sober listen to this song my
mother was on heroin and i played this
song for her and it helped her and she's
in rehab now
the ones that touch me the most are
stuff like this and i tell this story
shop
i had a gun loaded sitting on my counter
this is from a fan
and i put on a playlist and i smoked a
joint and poured myself a glass of
whiskey to numb myself before i killed
myself
and i just couldn't quit listening to
your song
and it made me realize i wasn't alone oh
wow so i get a thousand of those a year
let's say
999 of them are telling a fish story yep
they tell they caught a [ __ ] six
cents guppy and told me it was a 12
pound bass right let's imagine 999 are
exaggerating the truth one of them but
one of them was dead [ __ ] serious and
he was gonna kill himself that night
yeah man i gotta keep doing this yeah
i've gotta find a way to find i gotta
touch so many more thousands of people
to keep finding those ones well then
don't go get a house and fade to black
i'm not i'm not i was saying that you
know i was saying good yeah it's like
i'm not trying to touch people for the
money yeah i could cash out and [ __ ]
roll off you know i misunderstood that
yeah
the cowboy kid right away because even
your girl can afford a bunch of horses
she is [ __ ] awesome yes she is
stable cowboys aren't worried about
touching people
they got a horse and a lady to take care
of that's all they care about man
cowboys are good folks that's my point
they got this [ __ ] they got to take care
of they don't have wi-fi because your
girl's blowing up on only fans too she's
still crushing she's still her patreon
you know her podcast the dumb blog
that's why i was [ __ ] i can't believe
dude
i know
i miss reading you're supposed to be
honest we're homies and if i just called
you like yo
she never agrees she's like yeah i love
shop that's your homie i'll come do it
for sure because her podcast is crushing
on patreon god damn it the dumb blonde
podcast like i'm really proud of her
like i just looked her up before like we
came on because i i saw one of your
posts about her and
and i saw a little clip yeah i mean it
was hot she is it's like her patreon is
doing
only fans numbers for her does she know
any other dumb blondes
a ton
yeah dude my wife is the [ __ ] so bad
yeah
even that i just love that yeah she just
[ __ ] she's just crushing man dude you
know what you need to go on because
she's not only fan dude i can't believe
i think of this he might be in new york
or vegas adam 22. dude you know it's
plug time if you want to hear that
that's my most [ __ ] up story
it's my boy too
i called adam and said hey yo i'm coming
to la i'll be here these days because
linda and bunny are cool right and i was
like his girl and i was like yo i'm
coming to [ __ ] l.a i want to do the
party's right you're not going to
believe this
i'll be in nashville when you're in l.a
uh yeah i know he was he's traveling
because i was trying to do a circuit
dude yeah he was like probably go vegas
to nashville or whatever yeah for sure
so he hit me thursday he was in
nashville before i flew out and i was
like i had like a sinus infection that
slept all day yeah so i seen it the next
day and missed him but he he wanted to
take me uh me and bunny out to dinner
and [ __ ] adam oh that'd be cool you
unplugged oh sure yeah dude i'm trying
to do no jumper yes you know what i'm
saying on there
no adam's the homie he's built such a
great business and he's just such a
genuine [ __ ] yeah he's such a good
person man hey jeff are you going to put
a diaper on that drink what are we doing
john
we're talking about the rainbow you're
like i'm the last american bro it took
me an hour and 27 minutes to finish a
double shot of the kilometer like shots
here's the rest of the talking about
my heart refilled mine man you didn't
really mind what's going on i was over
here i was listening you guys talk i
thought you were worried about me not
having a coaster i was like why do you
care about wood no [ __ ] you wouldn't
need a coaster if you were drinking that
[ __ ]
together what are you worried about
there jelly roll cares about friends
yeah he's another guy
independent like the bad man's
building a business like you he's got a
ton of other projects coming out of no
jumper oh dude what he's doing like with
the only fans and like the podcast would
they you know hook up with girls and his
wife i'm like dude it's brilliant no
everything he does i mean you know it's
not my business model but for like yeah
he's like the steve jobs
in america come on yeah and his girl's
so bad yeah and the best part is how he
just like
is crossing into pop culture now because
i just watched him do the podcast tour
he did everything from dj akka's
academics to kfc radio to schulte to
[ __ ] chelsea to barstow all the bar
he went did the whole bar stool circuit
it's like just watching him was like
there's no and he's such a cool dude man
such a such a good guy he's the most
downer's like yeah man let's go put a
single person on this screen without a
ton of tattoos i don't know we don't
face that dude i'm [ __ ] happy but
like i was like with uh with adam's two
too i was like god damn man like he has
so many interesting like wild guests
he's talking to me i'm like this sucks
no i thought a nip
oh dude he so when he has a show it's
our only fans yeah the the plug where
they interview interviews
and then [ __ ] like [ __ ] them
i have trouble booking guests that i
don't [ __ ] and you thought and you
thought you were [ __ ] had life
figured out right yes
and he makes all the money like oh dude
it's nuts
it's [ __ ] interesting
yeah yeah they they handle their
business man it's like me and bunny they
just [ __ ] get their [ __ ] done and do
it right no he's brilliant he's a
[ __ ] sweetheart of a guy he's really
really really [ __ ] smart if i
remember right he like grew up on the
east coast moved out here forever ago
like was bmx bike dude or something yeah
bmx bike yeah yeah it's got a really
cool story and he's been doing it
forever you know i discovered like a lot
of the early
change of rap music over there like
xxxtentacion the first time i heard a
helmet through no jumper yes the first
time i heard six nines music was through
no jumper first time i heard pouya the
buffet boys the [ __ ] suicide boys all
that [ __ ] i heard first uh juice world
all that [ __ ] these are real bands right
yeah yeah
cause adam knows
he got all that crazy hair and stuff
right yeah yeah i know that guy yeah
this can't be you're like
something straight out of american pie
right you know what i'm saying this is
it's like the more i talk to you the
more i love you yeah and then hate you
no but also random stuff it's like what
the [ __ ] is jelly roll he's like stifler
yeah that's the thing like you could
play for a minute i go you'd change my
life i'd become obsessed with the guy
the next day i was in germany we went to
this stupid uh bar that was like also
like a museum and it was dedicated to
the ramones never [ __ ] heard of these
girls
i wanted to drink i was in germany i
[ __ ] it i'll go check out these
fruitcakes
i'm looking at the thing i was like i'm
because i'm a comedian so i started
going this is look at this joey ramon
[ __ ] weirdo yeah but then i'm getting
drunk i'm listening to the songs i'm
walking through all the stuff i was like
actually these guys are pretty dope so
then and i'm making bank on this nbc
travel show so i'm you know i'm getting
like 50 grand in episodes i i text my
boys back in lego you know when i get
home when i miss all you guys when i get
home we're all going to ramone's concert
you know because i just learned about
them literally like 10 minutes ago and
my friends were smart and they're like i
hope you're sitting down bud
they're all dead
there's one that's sort of alive who was
barely in the band
and uh but like that's how i am like i
after like two nights i like did a deep
dive on goo i learned everything about
the ramones i'm like a huge fan so it's
like i just don't know about this stuff
but then when i like when i see it a lot
of those rappers are yeah a lot some are
they were super underground
quite a few of them passed away
yeah yeah
like i saw some clips of him he he gets
concerned for these guys like little xan
we're having on the show and be like
dude how are you spending your money
like yeah he's actually concerned for
some of these yeah he'll also edit stuff
out like if he was saying if it's like
uh a rapper beef with another rapper and
you talk [ __ ] that's fine but yeah it's
like a gang member and another gang
member using certain verbiage that he
knows gonna shed violence
he's not basically
which a lot
what are you doing with your money i
like i like logan paul and them do that
too i think it's cool when they did the
uh island boys podcast they were like yo
what are you investing in yeah
yeah they walked off the island boys
yeah because they felt like they were
being pumped up because like michael was
shooting straight out he was like yo
worst case scenario you can sell your
jewelry and you'll have a backup right
now what do you think
is like what yeah my yeah this mike and
logan are smarter yeah they're [ __ ]
awesome yeah smarter than the island
boys
i mean it's close i don't know what's
going to happen with those boys
yeah yeah i got tuned out
yeah it just started getting weird when
they started having four or five of them
i was like i'm done
and they popped up on my fy they were
like [ __ ] they were just like girl
they were like babies kids yeah they
multiple also what i liked
are they from yeah it was very strange
that whole thing just taught me so much
about life dude we tried to get my king
sting oh really yeah i mean they were
going to light them up oh i'm tall they
would have you know the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
up part is they would have not figured
it out no that's what we all want to
just fire in the hole and they would
have just been like fire flames
their manager was like i don't think so
they have a manager
i was their brother
let me tell you something anytime
somebody's making money there's somebody
over there trying to that's true but
those boys can't still be making like
where they how they make money now like
the island boy i'm confused by it
because he'll call you like again all
rappers do this but he goes on tick tock
and he's like
you know first person to say like like
you know put a hundred thousand dollars
in cash on their tick tock like can
criticize whatever
they're stunting a lot right i don't
know how they make money i honestly
don't because they're terrible live
performers they don't seem to have any
songs they look ridiculous if you could
explain their business model to me i'd
love it you know i mean there has to be
some some money there has to be
something like someone's paying them to
promote on instagram there has to be but
i watched uh on world star then get beat
up in a mall yeah
yeah oh really but just having that
following you could make money
but yeah well i can tell you right now
that ethica is supporting them all right
so would you consider this selling out
to be like the joke of the internet but
then be like but i'm getting paid
wouldn't you think that's kind of
selling it depends on you know what
you're and where you are in your own
life you know what's your personality
they think they're being offended
yeah it's like exactly like whatever
your personal integrity is you know
and i i don't think they have kids but
that's where [ __ ] starts to become
really subjective because at the end of
the day
yeah because at the end of the day i'm
not gonna like
there's you can't make there's nothing i
could do that provides for my daughter
that you could judge me for right no as
a father
you know what i'm saying but also i
don't think they have kids like if
they're a stock i'm not investing in
that
yeah i'm not gonna believe they're gonna
be [ __ ] huge in five new to five
that's five months yeah there yeah it's
but i'll there was one where he was
getting i have those same shoes that's
disappointing but there's uh
there's uh island boys it's
job goes home and throws balloons
those exact kicks i get my suplex jen
you're with me i was like they were uh
they're on world star i love world star
but he was getting beat up by his baby
mama so i apparently he punched her so
he does have kids and then no no uh
sorry not baby mom just his girlfriend
she was loping his head yeah yeah and
he's crying and it was lameness he was
crying he's not allowed to hit back
i feel like he had his hands full yeah
okay those guys are disastrous you know
what i could be wrong but i'm going to
give you my guess right now my guess is
they're on
xanax heavy 100 percent code
they're on something yeah it completely
separates i agree from reality right it
just feels that way you know
[ __ ] man because they don't seem to have
a whole lot of worries do they yeah they
don't yeah they also don't seem like
they leave the house a lot i didn't see
any pitchers that were like in the
street yeah i don't think they have you
know i think this is some weird
stay-at-home make a lot of money if you
can right now drugs this is a lot of
home pictures what's that with a kid
though oh no he's got a kid though he's
telling me that's not a his kid happy
father's day to the men out there taking
care of the so he does have a kid does
that matter this is a random child i
found it's a white baby you know what
the other side of this is
the weird flip side of life could be
these dudes could be geniuses this could
all be a gimmick they could be selling
[ __ ] sitting on a mountain of cats
investing in half of miami right now
and they come over and talk to you off
camera like hey shop really inspired by
your story sit down and go yeah my
[ __ ] yeah
what the [ __ ] just happened i was just
talking to you about andy kaufman of the
rap world yeah yeah
literally in the suv i just it's so
strange dude yo i'm late to the party i
just watched the jim carrey movie about
kauffman oh great oh yeah
party yeah dude
you know he's so good you know what made
me watch it i watched the documentary
that just came out whatever you see how
he gets so into the air
andy kaufman's family went up to him was
like dude you are andy kaufman yeah i
hated him he was like i'm not that
everyone's working with him i was like
hey you're an [ __ ] he tried to
convince him that he was yeah he tried
to go he tried to have like this moment
with andy's mom or dad i can't really
remember which one
and he was like basically convinced them
that he was channeling andy and they
were actually talking to andy and i was
like that's a little gross yeah yeah
that part if it helps him the only thing
is like he stayed in such character he
was a method actor that uh wrestler on
there jerry lawler jerry lawler when
they're at craft services he got mad
though no jerry lawler beat him up yeah
put his hands up jared lawler said andy
was actually really sweet but when they
were filming and doing things andy would
get into andy mode he goes jim just
acted like andy mode the whole time but
like really andy was like polite and
like respectful and like that's
interesting knows that it's a schtick
and so it's like but jim didn't get to
study real andy he had to study
or whatever like he he thinks he's
channeling the real land he called me
he's chill channeling like the
entertainer yeah he did a great job jim
carrey is brilliant he said but it was
just
the same app he annoyed everybody that's
when he got crazy yeah after that movie
he went crazy i believe that which is so
that happens a lot though isn't that
what they said happened to heath yep and
jack nicholson for a little bit yeah
yeah oh uh what's his [ __ ] name the
guy he's in uh
he did uh nightcrawler brilliant actor
jake he's like once i did nightcrawler
he's like even now i'm still not such a
good movie he's like i got so involved
that guy was such a narcissist and like
sociopath i was like i'm still not
normal from really you know and then i
go but also super acting it's like i
played a tmz report
no no it was that he was uh he was like
uh
like he was like a video guy for the
news
accidents and [ __ ] great movie great
it's the dodge uh challenger are y'all
watching anything right now i don't
historically watch [ __ ] obi-wan i just
feel because of the tour that i've been
on for so long hey come on this tour has
been forever so i've been on the bus
watching [ __ ] we've been watching the
offer
it's about when al reddy went to go make
the godfather and he had to work out a
deal with joe colombo oh my gosh and my
boy uh uh
uh [ __ ] um
he's in [ __ ] talking who am i miles
tillerson it's fire yeah yeah it is
actually worth the [ __ ] watch wait
why do you think star wars is gay you
love stories
but not the not that i'm i like the
original star wars these these spin-off
oh they're so money play it's so good i
mean if your ball's deep and i guess it
it's good man it's a good story and it's
also like the dave felloni's making it
to john favreau like they know what
they're doing the story's [ __ ] dope
yeah yeah they're good they're better i
would argue than them really yeah
you know i want to watch them but i'll
be honest to tell you that i didn't
watch some of the first ones yeah so i'm
afraid i would be but they over
explained that stuff in the beginning is
it bill burnham too bill birzinham uh
uh what's his name kamal non-john i
don't know how to say his name not
johnny yeah brian posane there's a
comedian like every episode but also
like the acting's phenomenal it's really
good i got really into bates motel yeah
five seasons and i think it's an older
show i don't know
all right dude
one of them will warp you in let's watch
winning time
it was so good winning time
he knows uh winning time i love you know
what's the best family well fire
he's mr laker probably probably get in
trouble for sharing this but
jeannie uh
we would text every episode and she's
like yep that happened yep that happened
this is true and like jerry bus magic
all these guys are getting mad like
that's that's what happens
that's not what happened but these are
things like everything that's on that
show is true yeah the difference is they
don't know what they said so everything
they said is just hollywood writers
making up the script but they know they
don't know what they said no so they
have to make up that dialogue right and
then they do know what
so if you're watching it and it's like
there if someone's depicting me i'd be
like i would never say that it's like
yeah i know but they don't know what you
said so they have to make that i know
that this situation happened they
probably made him sound smarter but
jerry west like i wasn't an [ __ ] but
then most people were like yeah you were
famous that's what they said right it'd
be like if they made a documentary about
me and they show my life exactly it is
and then i get mad at all the bad things
like hey why they made me sound like a
drunk it's like jeff you're a drunkard
you can't get they're not gonna to just
cherry-pick you know jenny bus he was
like you want to go later i'm like sure
i figured you know i don't know
mid-level seats right
we're sitting in
jenny buss's seat yeah ownership we're
sitting next to her he's talking [ __ ] to
her about the players on the court we're
like very good friends so like i guess
she's just getting drunk
yeah i'd love to go yeah that's the best
part
he's talking [ __ ] to her about the
trades and stuff oh my god i was like
dude relax also i know nothing they
could have like i don't even know if
that like how would happen like i can't
believe you got rid of careers yeah he
was giving a [ __ ] for getting really
crucial i'm like he's like half of the
[ __ ] yeah i thought it was fire i
thought the whole show was fine
so well [ __ ] so i didn't make me look
at anybody in a bad light i like i
respected jerry west right because jerry
west probably saw the first two episodes
where it made him look like a psycho
yeah uh which he was and then and then
the rest of this series made him look
great exactly i don't think he watched
the rest of the series he just
made him look like a dude that was
[ __ ] determined to be a [ __ ]
winning franchise and then what he had
to do to make it happen and was a
[ __ ] obsessed compulsory [ __ ] nut
case but that's [ __ ] awesome so the
way that you're like i don't know if
you're big into sports
are you big for sure other never mind
but like i always tell people like
they'll be like i don't like basketball
and i recommend winning time and they
love it same with star wars
you don't have to like star wars to
watch mandalorian like you could like
think sci-fi stuff's dumb space i don't
like space stuff but if you watch like
the mandalorian you go oh this is a
[ __ ] western it's a western i'm
watching i'm gonna i'm gonna because of
you i'll be on the bus this weekend
you'll love it episode one you go i'm in
yeah but have you seen yellowstone or
anything oh yeah for sure all right
westworld
i love cowboy [ __ ] yeah no red dead red
i thought i wouldn't get into it i
thought it was too dialogue driven which
one well what yellowstone and my wife
was like you gotta watch it and then i
was like i refused forever
when i watched like one random episode
it wasn't even like episode one season
one and after that episode i was like
stop as soon as it was over i was like
restart i love you
don't watch another episode it's
information heavy they kind of have to
set up the whole thing
i went back and watched [ __ ] i knew we
finished the whole i would argue 1883 is
better than yellowstone i'm a big brawl
fan so i thought that was just fine
dude my family you know we go to hawaii
like everybody else does since
yellowstone we only go to montana now
right like that
i'm telling you that sure
do you play montana
community i did uh boise boys idaho yeah
yeah yeah
you know yeah not montana yeah yeah but
uh they've got good montana guys are
they really
or you play like buildings like public
schools
and then butte and then uh there's one
more big city out there but lucas sealy
booked it you would sell out i love that
yeah but boys is one of the best venues
i've ever played middle of pandemic
theater
it sells out i'm getting ready to uh go
out and the manager comes in the back
and goes
it's
right at the start of pandemic she was
hey there's protesters outside of you
why
and uh i was like oh because everyone's
not vaccined and they don't have
masculine she goes no they're anti-mass
i go
wait and they're protesting my show yeah
did they not get the memo i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't care about it to me it's
free choice do what you want if you want
a mask i don't care where i'm at want to
be vaccinated get vaccinated i don't
care for sure and i go i'll solve this
easy i'll go out there she goes no you
can't go there i'll go out there so
you're there hey
nobody in here is wearing a mask and
they're like what i'm like no it's all
good they went let's move on yeah they
got the same team
on the same team guys
to the local waffle house yeah
we gotta go we got a night off i'm the
chili's yeah um what's the um i'm trying
to remember it's missoula yeah
that's where i fly into it it's like
billings missoula yeah we got in a fight
leaving missoula on the way to a
billings or something and we stopped at
like
an off diner on tour this is many moons
ago
and i'll never forget i was in the we
was in the restaurant it was only a few
of us awake so we're just in our eating
and like
randomly all these old cowboys pull up
and i was like a bar must have just let
out or something right it's like two in
the morning or something they're tough
boys and i remember right then i was
like
i looked at my dude i was like it's
fitting to happen
before they walked in i could just knew
i was like i knew where we were i knew
what the energy was going to be i was
like we're for sure fixing to get a
fight that sucks though why yeah i just
you know how you just feel it you know
what i mean i'm just like this is going
to happen like it just they were rowdy
walking in i was like your boys were
eating like salads for sure yeah we're
in there we're like caesars yeah we're
in there just we just looking looking
great
i'm the only one that looks like a
cowboy the rest of us look like rockers
and rappers you know what i mean
so i'm just like it's just going to
happen you know what i mean
and uh when we get up to leave
what one of them one of them goes
well i hate it when the encounter
[ __ ] come to this town and i
was like here go here it is
and i was like
please don't pick this out of the air
one of my dudes like what kind of
[ __ ] you talking about he's
like just oh
oh [ __ ] whatever you know he just had
some you know he said something funny
and i was just like
and then you know one thing turns to
another we end up getting into a
full-blown fistful this is way early in
my career but i'll you remember moments
like that because sure we only fought
you know a handful of times a handful of
times on tour ever you know what i mean
and every one of them's always because
we're such a big group
it's like on tour you know you know how
y'all move it's like there's always a
ton of us so yeah if we ever get in the
fight it's because there's a ton of them
correct you know what i'm saying yeah
it's like it never turns out like most
of the time two or three drunk dudes
will look and be like oh that's an
entire bust full of yeah nobody's
getting jumped well you're getting 30
fights you're going to remember all 30.
yeah for sure right yeah
do you do you have like i have like uh i
forget where i was at somewhere in the
midwest and i come out
and i look out and there's like a bike
biker guys in the front row yeah i
started making fun i go what uh what
it's sons of anarchy uh extras just get
done would you guys just get out and
they're not laughing here they go i'm
like what yeah i'm like oh that's weird
and i keep looking i see one get up go
to the bathroom i see hell's angels on
the back
oh [ __ ] yeah
real [ __ ] dude so i get to the
back but they bought the vip they're in
the front reserve vip there's like 12 of
them yeah and uh i'm in the back and i
tell my brother like you see the [ __ ]
the hell's angel in the front he goes
yeah they're in line dude for the meet
and greet i'm like oh [ __ ] what you
guys making fun of them they're the nice
people ever for sure and then i'll never
forget this the main guy goes bro we own
the strip club up the street man you and
your brother it's on us at least we can
do we listen to a show all the time he
goes the birds are sucking the boys off
and i was like yeah the birds yeah
what's that man he's like the girls oh
no he's like all those poor that's like
how i talk
poor birds yeah i think you want a gum
like [ __ ] yeah yeah and then he's like
all right man we'll wait for him at the
back and you know we can follow us there
my brother's like bro we're not going oh
yeah those angels strip yes
now they're waiting at the [ __ ] door
you get those like rough dudes that you
show all the time like when we're in
portland
big i don't know what he does proudly
cause bro you need anything you let us
know as a kid yeah
i i don't know what i need but uh thank
you thank you yeah i'll take your
support my man
they're cool you know what it is they're
they're great people because one they're
not a fan of much as a group correct so
the [ __ ] they share as a group they're
like oh no we this is like we're gonna
ride for this yes right it's like their
culture is like whatever they're into
they're into whatever they're not
they're not yes so they're into it
they're like we [ __ ] with you i do feel
like bikers are very sweet that way like
they're like family married they all
just said they're they're rough but
their problem is literally with [ __ ]
that has nothing to do with us right no
it doesn't involve for sure like i
respect the epitome of some street [ __ ]
like if those dudes have a problem with
some dudes it's a real it's not like uh
we're drunk bikers trying to fight some
dudes at a bar yeah this is like some
real like you need to get the [ __ ] out
of here we got a real problem also don't
call them a biker gang in front of them
they go motorcycle club yeah we're a
motorcycle okay yeah whatever you want
to call it whatever
they're awesome mother great struggle
mob to me struggle towards all the time
and meets with all of them he has them
you know he plays bike week and that's
his like culture because he rides yellow
is the same way he rides so he's heavy
in the culture they just come to my
shows and always take care of them but
we had a show i'll never forget this one
where's in charlotte and i'd like to
think it was the outlaws because we had
a lot of hell's angels come out in some
cities it was always different
but we're in charlotte north carolina
pull up struggle you'll see he looks
like a bugger
by the way he's [ __ ] like yoked up
all jacked and [ __ ]
and put yellow wolf crash site no that's
a pokemon yeah on its own yeah that's so
that's no he did a song with yeah
they've had a lot of records and then he
was close with bubba sparks too right
yeah for sure yeah but you see
struggling he's wearing a cut right
there but strokes doesn't it's not a
motorcycle club cut but it's still
looking like he's struggling to find
weights am i right for sure yeah dude
you should see them now go
right now and every struggle is like
right type and struggle generally
it's like first of all he was fat fat
and then he came we did like five years
in federal prison and came home and was
like
[ __ ] yeah at him damn he's jack this
is dude
tell me he doesn't look like inmate
number seven six nine five four three
two guys like that love us they love
comedians yeah no for sure no so he just
looks the part but he'll call me every
now and then they're like yo i'm sitting
in the hell's angel's homie but i come
out of the back of [ __ ] look he just
looks like that cow look at him look at
having the best struggle having that
dude
look at him just balling with his
struggles i thought that was so awesome
that he posted that that wasn't a
struggle at all yeah for sure
jane's name to throw
no for sure he's a [ __ ] he's just a
[ __ ] animal now yeah i knew him
because uh when they did the nashville
mineconf mean my struggle
yeah
it does because when they did the
nashville uh
uh kind of documentary thing on vice yes
you struggles and uh
and uh bubba absolutely 100 yep yep
what's some of the biker gangs like
what's some of the names hell's angels
outlaws so we were at porn star karaoke
in the valley right that's it used to be
a good place the pandemic shut it down i
don't know if that part about that place
too it's dope so what they do is once a
week on a certain night i remember for
over a decade it'd be they get all these
porn stars and the porn stars would
basically host a karaoke night i heard
about this like wait there's porn stars
at a dive bar and like you sing karaoke
and they'd be like 10 porn stars but
like four like famous ones sounds
awesome it was dope and you just get to
like go hang out and like a lot of
creeps show up so like you look like a
rock star because they're like i would
actually [ __ ] that guy for normal yeah
you're like not a creep so we're there
we're having fun we're just kind of
watching we're drinking the owner knew
who i was so that helps also like that
made me very flattered or whatever but
then all these dudes came in
and they're wearing vests and they're
like
they don't know they want any jokes or
anything like like very serious like
biker vests yeah there's 20 of them 20
guys in a small dive bar there's a lot
outlaws and they sit down and it was it
was the outlaws the mongols mongols
and um
my buddy brant was like starstruck my
buddy brian tobler was like you know
what those are i was like i don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] you know that right i
don't know anything yeah
he goes those that's like one of the
most famous gangs in the world so i'm
gonna go get a picture with him he goes
no no no no like don't go up to those
guys i gotta be fine dude and he's like
no and they like kept me from like going
up to these guys but that'd be a bad
idea these dudes they watched character
like this
like there's some guys sucking a
character we're all laughing there's a
bunch of
[ __ ] porn stars going like haha like
everyone everyone's having fun except
these guys well they're they're just
probably for the porn star oh my god
they don't wanna hear your shitty they
were so big we're gonna poach [ __ ] on
the way
they're just waiting till last call
yeah but like there's something cool
about it i mean i know i shouldn't like
no there's something but it was
something cool about that community like
this like group there's a higher
polarizing about it right yeah they
don't live by the same rules you know
you know they're playing a game where if
they get caught they're going away for
like it's like mafia and it's funny how
they identify themselves openly like the
cut will say president yes vice
president on the vet commander prospect
brother and there was a guy dove you
know what i'm saying you're like what
bro there was a young guy not a young
guy but he was the lowest on the ranks
and he was carrying all the drugs and
weapons yeah yeah because if they he's
not pouched then he's
the guy that takes the fall yeah he's
not well i would like to think earnestly
being kind of presumptuous i would think
maybe he was just carrying their keys to
their motorcycles well that's nice
how [ __ ]
good standing citizens had drugs and
guns that's right but you know uh
the uh the hell's angels that you know
they're a straight-up corporation
business for sure they have the baddest
lawyers you know yeah i had a buddy owns
a i won't say his name very famous he
has a clothing company
that he used to know
but uh he had a clothing company and he
copied the hell's angels you know how
the back says california he copied that
and then that it was like patches and
then it where it says hell's angel he
had his company's name underneath his
california it was a motorcycle he copied
them no not they sent him a seasoned
assist a day later and put on site he's
like they're gonna do anything i was
like
i can't do anything he's walking with
his girl down beverly hills mm-hmm they
all pull up of course like if you sell
one more [ __ ] item just like ours i'm
telling y'all problems yeah didn't
threaten him would just like legally
threaten him i don't know it was
physical yeah just legally threatened
him yeah he took it down the next
[ __ ] they're not gonna do anything
it's not taco bell yeah yeah we're
talking about the hell yeah yeah they're
probably gonna they're not gonna do
anything like that they're probably
gonna do something that's a bad idea
the hell's they just until you stop
doing something i'm not calling their
bluffs
they're like disney bro they're lawyers
we've been to a lot of clubhouses we've
left a lot of shows and went to the
clubhouse afterwards with them i know
how you do it i love you jeff growing up
son i'm proud of you man
for all your lack of cocaine and hip-hop
knowledge you make up for it
but i'm here to be tough yeah that's it
[ __ ] i just love this
it is 10 20 p.m gentlemen
ain't that awesome and we're just
sitting here you know that means
five times
what about y'all's whole concept of what
y'all do is the coolest wildest [ __ ]
ever
we're literally just sitting in here
getting smacked drunk yeah but we want
him out he's talking about his angels
i'm two hours into this podcast like how
in the [ __ ] did we end up here
athletes want to be rock stars rock
stars want to be athletes comedians want
to we it's all yeah
we all like respect each other i think
it's the respect of the i want to be a
motorcycle gang but yeah
i want to be a cowboy bro oh you could
do that
i used to not like westerns my entire
life and then i played the game red dead
redemption at the same time ready to
remember you too
do you still play games what's that you
still like if the game's good enough i
know i slaughtered that red dead
redemption i have recently came out at
the same time as the ballot of buster
scruggs the code
oh [ __ ] oh my god since then i've been
obsessed with cowboys yeah all cowboy
[ __ ] you're playing video games yeah
what do you like yeah dude listen you
don't listen i just did a radio tour
shop i have spent
like
i'd say more than eighty percent of this
year on the bus really that's a tough
gig dude it's me and my wife were like
grinding we wrote down how often we've
been sleeping at the house recently like
i've slept in our bed heartbreaking and
it was it was sad when she brought it to
my attention like do you know you slept
in your bed nine times in the last
eighty percent oh my god that's a
sacrifice it's like when you see bert
tomorrow me and him we're talking about
it when he i was talking about how
yeah i mean it's a good thing a bad
thing like i can't leave my kids for
more than three days like yeah i'm
physically ill i can't do it and bert's
like man i i wish i was like days like i
go on tour tomorrow on my tour bus i'm
gone for two months no i watched i told
him i was like here's the difference
bert and i was like i'm not knocking as
a dad that's your path and you get it
done your great dad i physically can't
do it so my agent called me today was
like hey man we got your international
tour you're gone for six months it's
whatever 10 million i couldn't do it
that's because you're a good guy i
literally can do it whoa whoa i'm not
going to let you call bird a bad guy
he's my favorite guy
yeah
bird goes virtually
i love bert but bertrand next to the
show was like i've been on the road i've
been doing this stuff it was fine it was
time for me to take time for myself
and he does a netflix show he takes time
for himself where hangs out with caitlyn
jenner and nikki glazier
yeah yo when my when uh miss pat flipped
on that [ __ ] yeah i was like what is
happening yeah so how do you play games
on the road
uh just hook up the xbox and do the
wi-fi on the bus
uh xbox two like a tv on your bus yeah
for sure there's a company called games
g-a-e-m-s
seriously look it up and if you want
i'll set you up i'll set you up with
them they'll give you this thing it's
basically like a briefcase i play it in
the airport really
g-a-e-m-s is like it's a little
briefcase you travel with and then
you're just so hard to make yourself
spell games wrong right if you can find
a g-a-e-m-m-s
if you find like an outlet at the
airport you can just play with this
briefcase the briefcase holds all your
[ __ ] but he's playing on the bus man i
know but this one i can do this in the
airport for sure like you just plug it
in like that it has an hdtv screen on
the top part and it opens up
dude they hooked up my buddy eric
griffin they hooked up uh oh yeah you
got our guys
and then uh but it's it's the best
playing system hdtv you just put your
system right in the thing no i'm gonna
look it up yeah it's [ __ ] so sick
yeah it's like
baby birds on my phone yeah yeah but i
play i play like red dead like at the
airport we're playing like call of duty
a lot in shows we're doing good [ __ ]
we're doing a lot of war zones yeah we
just i don't know i've been spending so
much time on the [ __ ] bus it's like
just whatever i can be happy to be home
though yeah oh [ __ ] yeah i got two weeks
off coming here saturday i got shows
we're out in florida um jacksonville uh
thursday with brantley gilbert
friday panama city beach with brown and
gilbert that'll be fun and saturday
somewhere i would have known if i forgot
but it was somewhere right down there on
that coastline
it's gonna be [ __ ] super fire but the
cool thing is when you were talking
about that conversation we have a bird i
got to watch it i got to watch uh bert
when he talked to chrissy d about the
kids and the traveling on the road and
you know they had a really emotional
moment i've been that's another thing
i've been catching up on boy i've caught
up on pod cast bubble yeah there we go
run them jelly roll tournaments one time
yeah yo the next time i'm here i hope to
come here before then but in september
i'm playing the honda center in anaheim
i know it's like oh wait
dude
i'll be at the honda center in september
i also played in the honda center not
comedy i fought there really
do you remember every one of your fights
oh yeah so that's what i was saying
earlier like if you fight a lot like you
remember all your friends in the ufc
though because it's stressful no but i'm
saying like oh yeah like it was
yesterday every moment you could go how
did you do again
yeah yeah i bet you don't remember all
those
there's at least a smoker
yeah the honda one i remember i fought
uh gabriel gonzaga uh there that was a
big deal yeah that's the shine down tour
will you fight all the people i don't
like
all right look at this dude yeah yeah
it's down there somewhere later it's
like going yeah we're getting close oh
they're really close
yep it's october then you're in uh do
you ever have the comics open for you
yeah and i'm gonna announce a bunch of
dates oh [ __ ] dude yeah red rocks
amphitheater yeah sold out that's a big
deal yeah
remember we talked about this when
you're in nashville december 9th i'm
going to text the unj again to remember
but i want y'all to come out i want you
to block that friday night yeah it would
be great we got to go we have to go
earnest and introduced me
the trick was he just came out kept it
fun and fast yeah yeah yeah he did like
three seven minutes or something like
this who keeps
a lot of crowd i've done there's only a
2 000 3 000 cap no one stay here 15
minutes i've done well in front of
musicians and then also
also the worst i've ever done was in
front of music yeah i bombed in front of
like some rapper named chingy in saint
louis i did so terrible
and i like sat on the floor i didn't
even want to sit on the couch and say i
don't deserve couches
have you ever seen this happen
dude they hated me so much i sat on the
floor and i leaned up against a mini
fridge and the magnet on the mini fridge
was a suicide hotline this makes sense
what was your biggest bomb oh that was
might have been in that was it for real
uh
i got a different biggest like on tour
would be uh pittsburgh was tough really
in front of a band in seattle so the
band goes the i was friends i met the
guy in a bar like a dive bar and he was
like dude this guy's dope i'll come see
him in giggles comedy club he saw me do
really well at giggles because it's a
comedy club yeah so then like two weeks
later he's like i was like i want to
bring some girls to your show and he
goes well um he goes i just talked to my
manager do you want to open for us and i
go nah nah i just want to come see you
and he goes all right so my manager said
they'll give you a free bar tab if you
come open for us so i said nah nah
because i was kind of an open mic i was
kind of new it's kind of green i do well
in comedy clubs but i wasn't like ready
for that not for you i've only been
doing a card for like two years yeah and
so then he goes he goes uh he goes all
right how about this my manager because
we're just going back and f text he goes
free bar tab and i give you 200 bucks
and at that point in my car i'm just
living in a car like kind of homeless i
mean homeless people don't have cars but
i had a car i slept in a car and so i
was like i can't say no to 200 bucks and
free drinks so i go [ __ ] it i'll do it
dude i bombed so hard that two guys got
kicked out of the venue because they
wanted to fight me
they're trying to get on stage yes
you know who's a beast jim brewer opened
for metallica oh jimbo is great yeah but
he i've seen him bomb before i mean like
the wrong venue is the wrong it's a
tough gig but jim brewer a lot of times
you know he cries oh he crushes you yeah
but still he might be the most famous
guy i've ever seen really bomb
you know what i think the sheer
difference is is the
standing and sitting
yeah like the idea of like most venues
like have a pit right that's standing
only so it's like
these they came here
to socialize
before music they're standing they're
talking there's a different mindset
where like when i go to comedy i'm
always sitting i've never seen a comedy
show that i was standing up for no i'm
always sitting it's always a ten of you
know you're coming to be attentive you
know what i mean yeah so i think it's
just a different mindset my biggest bomb
i have two but one of them was chelsea
as a musician yeah oh [ __ ] you think we
don't have to deal with the boo purge i
would love to hear this because i got
two great ones
the first one is chelsea handler invited
me to come speak at princeton with her
for a netflix documentary at princeton
so i'm like all right cool i'm coming
and she was like will you sing a couple
songs after you speak i was like yeah
whatever
so i come first of all i'm smoking weed
in princeton it looks like [ __ ]
hogwarts right
and we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ] we're
we're smoking out there we're getting
high we go to this little green room and
this stuff this is goddamn princess like
the library they made it like into a
netflix area where they're doing like a
serious film about white privilege or
something and i'm like [ __ ] i'm in
prison right yeah i can't believe i'm
here and i just love chelsea so i'm like
whatever and me and my guitar player in
the back and he's like what two songs
were gonna do
and i was like
these two and then in the bottom of the
ninth i was like we need to do this
certain song and he was like
young man looks at me he goes not the
crowd
i go i go now trust me man they're going
to feel it it's honest and real he was
like this ain't the place for honest and
real these are princeton kids yeah yeah
nobody's here on a [ __ ] scholarship
doc everybody paid millions of dollars
saying that trump you're not playing uh
tennessee state this isn't auburn he was
like princeton they're not going to feel
it nobody here has ever been through any
kind of struggle in their life
yeah for sure and i'm like their biggest
struggle for us over explaining things
to them
microaggressions
i'm like look i've never got to tell the
story full so
i get up there and we're talking and i
can tell that i'm not winning the crowd
over talking neither it's like a you
know the vibe you're feeling like two
minutes in like i'm saying funny stuff
and i'm like man this is brutal and
we're just having like dialogue
conversation and i'm just like you know
i'm being funny because
my whole thing in this
documentary was i just didn't you know
everybody else was there on some serious
[ __ ] and i was just there on some like i
want to be on netflix [ __ ] yeah right
you know what i mean
so they were like what do you think
about this i was like [ __ ] i don't man
i'm high i just came here because i'm in
princeton crickets i was like god that
should have worked yeah
yeah we play the first song and it's
kind of a moving song and they're kind
of just at least obligatory nodding so
when you know what's your pronoun yeah
right
so the second song it's called the
smoking section it's one of my favorite
songs i hope heaven has a smoking
section
and i do a bridge and i'm like yo if
you've ever lost someone you love then
put your hands up and sing this
[ __ ] whatever not one person not
a hand and i'm like i hope that and
never in my life have i done that part
and somebody didn't go sing it with me
princeton because again but i hope that
silence dude i was like
nobody listen i finished
and it was so brutal i would have been
like [ __ ] one person with the clap they
went
and when they realized nobody was riding
with them
yeah they realized they were wrong
oh sorry i clapped
i guess one poor soul felt bad and
thought maybe they'd get a little group
second one cypress hill aztec theater
love cypress hill um
san antonio texas
we come out on stage early in my career
2014 or something right
nobody knows our songs we're the first
to act on a cypress hill 25th
anniversary tour or some [ __ ] 20th
anniversary they're dying for cyprus
they are all
first time past like houston so like we
did louisiana i crushed we did
birmingham i crushed they took me
because it was the south yeah but this
was like as far west as i had ever been
or yeah i guess wherever san antonio
it's the first fan base hasn't touched
those parts they had no clue jelly roll
was a human i'm killing in houston so
i'm on a high horse i'm like we're in
the [ __ ] it's gonna be great
my wife's there we're just like courting
like we we haven't even like [ __ ] or
nothing like we kind of we're like
friending you
a big deal
i go up on stage in the first song i'm
like put your [ __ ] hands up and
no hands well
don't tell us what to do this is a show
like normally you can win with that at
least once no matter what if you overdo
it they'll quit putting their hands yeah
they're trying to at least get one early
in your career where people are like
yeah i put my hand up with whoever
doesn't say brazil do that
yeah well it's but you they don't
[ __ ] know me right now let's get
going but normally like i said you'll
get one you know where they're just like
all right we'll give you a chance we're
with you we'll show you we give you a
chance yeah not one i look stage right
and there's a group that have begun to
be the boo birds and i keep hearing them
periodically you know it's like 10 of
them
[Music]
like and i had a moment of clarity
between song one and two like a clear
moment of silence and all of them and
you just went boo
real quick and i was like i looked at
the details i dropped a goddamn song we
need to drown out the blue birds and i
know how the blue birds work
they spread fast yeah it is the early
coke it's an easy ride
it's like omni crown dude it's that new
very evil spreads fast i was like this
is it's gonna happen i went over and i
wrapped every bar of this verse in the
like this little group
i was [ __ ] almost in his nose and
it's like i had like a really aggressive
song yeah so i'm just [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] the more i did it
the more he kind of went
and then he went
like and at that moment i was like cool
and i didn't like crush
but at least i left with an obligatory
like she went over the blue bird yeah
yeah and your girls i prevented what
could have been a [ __ ] story
right you know because that's what hate
is hates like cowardly yeah but when you
look at him he goes all right i like
this guy yeah yeah when i cause i i
think i was giving him the look in his
face like i will let y'all beat me up
before i let you boo me like i will jump
down and y'all will have to kick my ass
in here before you get the other 2 800
people bowing dude was your girl at the
time like huh yeah she was like okay
well that's interesting he's a little
gangster
turns out he's human yeah i went to the
merch booth because back then you're
like after every show you're like yo i
do this every night y'all cypress hill
is not coming on this stage for 30
minutes no matter how much you chant for
him you might as well come buy a t-shirt
seven people came to the [ __ ] booth
that night it was
one of them i called the birthday
mexican the whole time he was there he's
like i didn't know you but i came to
meet you because this is my birthday
right and uh you know i didn't think i'd
like you but you're okay and it is my
birthday birthday yeah
do you have any tapes yeah yeah yeah
because this is my birthday
keep saying your birthday my man because
my wife was standing at the birth with
me both women she was like it's that
guy's birthday
yeah that's great
i love it man well it's [ __ ] 10 40
boys you gotta wrap this up yeah [ __ ]
sir hold on
i just wanna say like jelly roll
i love you i love you dude
so i listen to country radio all the
time his song son of a sinner which i
love so much number one song it start it
started popping up here dude yes sir
meaning on 105.1 oh yeah yeah yeah go
country yeah
congrats dude it's getting unreal man
thank you brother and thank you all for
always having me thank you for doing
this oh we [ __ ] love you man we'll
come back and come ellie and not come
here you did i had to come see the
establishment bubba
jelly uh jeff you're the band
thanks for having me man yeah i'm in
arizona this weekend oh this weekend
you're in i'm in arizona this weekend at
cb live in phoenix that'd be fun uh also
jelly roll yes sir hold on
july 28th
i'm in nashville i'm home at the cystic
fibrosis uh it's like a it's like we're
comedy for a cause
so july uh july 28 2022 that's this year
obviously july 28th uh i'm doing the i'm
doing the amphitheater
so that's good and then tampa florida
side splitters uh
it doesn't matter you're trying to get
through the ascend it's amphitheater or
sand amphitheater yep okay so i'm trying
to get people to come to that it's gonna
be venue i'll post it i'll come hang out
yeah it'll be fun we'll drink a bunch um
nashville's big arizona this weekend
yeah i'm also at the life factory on uh
next sunday for chicago because i'm
throwing the first pitch for the white
sox oh [ __ ] yeah doing the
pitch thing
i am all right i got you i'm making
these contacts thanks brother we're
trying to pitch for the giants the
pirates
all right jelly you guys coming up here
in jacksonville on june 30th yeah dude
you have a lot of dates july 1st july
15th you're in uh cancel bluff was that
iowa
uh you see them two weeks i told you i'm
finally home yeah i see you doug i hope
i'm out loud i'm not home july 28th
straight live oh you're doing frontier
days oh yeah we're doing frontier today
yo bro i might come into that tailgating
talk
do you know chancy uh i don't know i'm
doing it with co wetzel and um
nelly that night oh wow tailgating tall
boys is another big one uh bossier city
is gonna be dope and then september 2nd
rocklahoma kicks off the shine down tour
that would be me and shine down playing
amphitheaters and arenas everywhere it's
going to be [ __ ] nuts which will be
the honda center and then i have a bunch
of dates i'm fixing to announce that'll
go from october 15th until
chancey is in uh frontier days the same
time you are
are you doing a chancy you don't know
man
all right i don't know
what's he doing
he's a coach
you know he's doing it at the 28th
because cheyenne frontier days is eight
days long oh is it okay so he could be
another night
[Applause]
two different people from all right
how dare you
you know maybe just families there yeah
you know yeah there's a lot of big
artists there
no it's like an eight day thing so we're
like one night is i know my roster is me
co wetzel and nelly oh yeah
nelly yeah yeah some big yeah you know
that guy you ever heard him i heard him
saint louis june going down down baby is
this his issue shop fort wayne
july 14 16 fort wayne indiana new club
out there then san diego lab factory san
diego's july 21st 23rd baltimore is
august 4 through the 6th appleton is
september 8th through the 10th houston
boston tickets that thickboy.com or
fatkz.com all right guys love you jelly
thank you for doing this brother thank
you brother love you man keep going
jeff thank you brother thank you thank
you big girl
we're out